on aurait pu intituler cette session ap
hockey
sonar dont je vais vous parler des
conséquences du changement climatique
enfin pendant tout de suite quand même à
une partie qu'ils vont attendre un peu
donc la dernière fois je vous ai parlé
de la dynamique à l'oeuvre dans ce qu'on
a coutume d'appeler le changement
climatique
alors il ya une chose dont je vous ai
pas tout à fait j'ai pas tout à fait
terminé le tour d'horizon des dernières
fois parce que dans les substances que
l'homme mais dans l'atmosphère il ya
certes les gaz à effet de serre dont je
vous ai longuement parlé mais il ya
également une autre catégorie de
substance que les hommes mettent dans
l'atmosphère qui s'appelle des aérosols
et des précurseurs d'aérosols alors à
l'aérosol en langage physique c'est tout
simplement une suspension dans l'air de
particules liquide ou solide donc tous
les gens dans cette salle qui ont déjà
passé un balai il y en a quelques-uns
qui c'est arrivé
eh bien vous avez créé un aérosol à
cette occasion puisque vous avez créé
une suspension dans leur de particules
solides à si vous avez balayé un peu
énergiquement alors dans les dents les
éléments que l'homme mais dans
l'atmosphère et qui peuvent créer des
suspension dans l'air vous avez en fait
à la fois des éléments qui sont émis
directement sous forme de liquide de
solides et qu'ils vont ensuite créer des
suspensions par exemple la suit la
suisse est une suspension dans l'air des
particules de carbone
ça fait partie des aérosols et puis vous
avez des substances qui sont qui vont
créer les aérosols une fois d'anvers rct
vie sous forme gazeuse et c'est une fois
dans l'air qu'il se passe une réaction
qui va transformer ces particules en
enfin qu'il va transformer pardon les
substances chimiques en particulier qui
louent solide et alors là dedans vous
avez une catégorie très importante qui
est le dioxyde de soufre so2 qui une
fois dans l'atmosphère va créer des
particules de sulfate qui sont des
particules brillante et particulièrement
réfléchissantes pour la lumière solaire
et donc il ya cette particularité par
exemple que les carburants
particulièrement souffrent et qui sont
utilisés par la marine marchande on à
court terme un effet refroidissant qui
est plus important que l'effet
reichshoffen je dis bien à court terme
parce que les aérosols finissent par
être épurée de l'atmosphère notamment
par les précipitations
par exemple pour les aérosols souffrez
eh bien ça finit par donner des pluies
acides
le sulfate se dissout dans l'eau quand
il ya de l'eau et ça fait un peu d'acide
sulfurique qu'on aime beaucoup une fois
que ça arrive par terre vous avez
également un autre effet qui est
important dans les effets des aérosols
c'est que ces petites particules
liquides ou solides peuvent servir de
noyaux de nucléation et favoriser la
condensation de la vapeur d'eau pour
former des nuages et on s'est rendu
compte notamment que au dessus des zones
qui étaient très industrialisée les
nuages qui se formait avait une
caractère était formé de particules qui
était un peu plus fine et qui
précipitait un peu moins facilement donc
ça n'est fait pas nécessairement sur la
couverture nuageuse mais par contre sur
la tenue de cette couverture nuageuse ça
a également un effet donc les émissions
humaines peuvent --peu également un peu
modifié la nature des nuages que nous
allons trouver au-dessus de nos têtes
quand les particules émises g revient à
suit son noir évidemment ça intensifient
leur échauffement parce que ça augmente
la quantité de rayonnement solaire
absorbée par contre quand les particules
sont brillantes typique où les surfaces
les sulfates par dont celle inverse ça
va diminuer la quantité ça va augmenter
l'albédo et donc diminuer la quantité de
rayonnement solaire absorbée par la
surface donc ces aérosols
ils peuvent avoir un effet réchauffant
ou refroidissant en fonction de leur
nature
mais globalement ils partagent tous la
caractéristique d'être des espèces à
durée de vie courte
d'accord c'est tous c'est tout des
espèces qui vont avoir une influence sur
les échanges d'énergie dans l'atmosphère
qui sont dès qu'ils sont des effets a
raisonnablement
court terme donc ici vous avez un
panorama des différentes substances qui
sont émises dans l'atmosphère et qui ont
un effet sur l'art est essentielle ment
sur la réflexion du rayonnement solaire
sauf pour la suite
soupe en anglais ou black carbon voilà
sinon pour l'essentiel cd effet cédé
effet entre guillemets refroidissant de
court terme
ce graphique que vous trouvez dans à peu
près toutes les éditions des rapports du
giec fait à ce moment un bilan de
l'ensemble des effets reichshoffen et
refroidissant de toutes les substances
que l'humanité mais dans l'atmosphère
alors là l'unité qu'on utilise pour
faire le bilan radiatif de l'atmosphère
cd watts par mètre carré
on aurait pu utiliser des watts beaucoup
puisque l'atmosphère elle a une surface
de contact avec le sol qui est donnée
qui est connu c'est la surface de la
terre mais en l'occurrence on préfère
plutôt que de se balader avec des
multiples des watts avec 10 puissance 12
dans tous les sens en fait on préfère
raisonner en termes de watts par mètre
carré
si vous vous rappelez bien dans la
dernière fois enfin même si je vous
rappelez pas bien je suis si j'ai donné
leurs deux vendeurs l'ordre de grandeur
du rayonnement solaire qui parvient au
sol ses 200 watts par mètre carré c'est
un peu plus en fait mais c'est de cet
ordre de grandeur
l'ordre de grandeur de l'effet de serre
additionnel c'est également un peu moins
c'est 170 de mémoire watts par mètre
carré de l'effet de serre naturel pardon
et l'effet de serre additionnel
il est de l'ordre de 2 à 3 watts par
mètre carré
si on fait les effets plus et moins au
total dont ici vous avez les effets plus
notamment d
des gaz à effet de serre à longue durée
de vie ici vous avez tout un tas
d'effets un peu plus ou un peu moins
et en fait ici vous avez la résultante
avec la barre d'erreurs que vous voyez
là et vous voyez que la barre d'erreur
elle vient surtout de la partie aérosols
d'accord c'est surtout de là que vient
la barre d'erreurs donc l'effet global
de l'homme sur les échanges d'énergie
dans l'antre l'atmosphère et la surface
de la terre c'est bien un effet de
forçage positif bien qu'on rajoute de
l'énergie mais vous avez dans cette
histoire encore une fois les aérosols
qui ont un effet qui est négatif mais
avec une ampleur sur le avec une ampleur
mal évalué pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux alors une fois que on sait
qu'on a des effets reichshoffen et
refroidissant je vais vous expliquer
maintenant la logique d'une simulation
climatique
la logique d'une simulation climatique
elle demande de mettre deux choses en
entrée de la simulation
elle demande de mettre en entrée la
représentation du système physique donc
un modèle de climat et elle demande de
mettre en entrée
l'hypothèse avec laquelle on va
perturber ce système physique
c'est-à-dire des émissions alors
historiquement j'ai conservé la
présentation de cette manière parce que
historiquement c'était comme ça que
c'était fait maintenant c'est un peu
changé je vais vous expliquer quoi
historiquement le cheminement qui était
présentée était le suivant on fait une
hypothèse sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre cette hypothèse est elle
même conditionné par des hypothèses
économiques et autres populations et c
est ça conduit à avoir des trajectoires
possibles en ce qui concerne les
émissions futures alors noté une chose
importante c'est que dans le scénario
des missions ainsi fait les émissions
résulte de l'économie qui appelle de
l'énergie et donc par rapport à ce que
je vous ai expliqué au premier cours il
ya une aversion causalité dans la façon
de faire le scénario puisque c'est
normalement vous avez de l'énergie et ça
vous fait à la fois des émissions et de
l'économie d'accord donc la véritable
hypothèse d'entrée c'est pas l'économie
qui appelle d'énergie c'est l'énergie
qui par ailleurs fait de l'économie fait
des émissions qui fait aussi de
l'économie
donc on devrait avoir deux sorties d'une
même entrée qui sont le pib les
émissions et non pas les émissions comme
sortie du pib c'est clair on pas loin
c'est exactement ce que j'ai expliqué au
premier cours il n'empêche que les
scénarios d'émissions sont faits par des
économistes qui donc le inverse la cause
et qui vous disent il ya un pib ce pib à
peine de l'énergie enfin où ils
inversent le facteur limitant plus
exactement
donc les vous avez des scénarios
d'émissions et ses émissions voix elle
montait de descendre c'est des
hypothèses par principe une fois que
vous avez les émissions vous fait
rentrer ça dans un premier étage de
modélisation donc là vous avez déjà de
la modélisation dans laquelle vous avez
des évolutions de la concentration en
gaz à effet de serre parce qu'en fait le
vrai forçage du climat
c'est l'évolution de la concentration en
gaz à effet de serre si vous avez des
émissions qui augmente et que dans le
même temps les puis augmente votre
concentration ne bouge pas et donc ya
pas de forçage du système climatique
pour qui un forçage du système
climatique
il faut que ce soit l'épaisseur de la
couverture c'est-à-dire la concentration
qui augmente alors aujourd'hui dans les
dents les dans les rapports qui sont
présentés par le giec ce que vous avez
c'est directement des évolutions sur la
concentration donc quand vous voyez
écrit rcp quelque part maintenant dans
les documents scientifiques qui parle de
simulations climatiques
ça veut dire représentatif concentration
pas fouet et donc c'est directement des
hypothèses qui sont faites sur
l'évolution de la concentration et de la
on dérive les scénarios d'émissions
possible cette évolution de la
concentration on va donc la donner à
manger à un modèle de climat et ce
modèle de climat va ferraille plus ou
moins fort et il va vous dire comment il
fait ailleurs d'accord donc il va aussi
on va passer beaucoup de temps
aujourd'hui à regarder ça donc il va
vous dire ça chauffe ça pollue l'eau ici
ça se refroidit là ça fait mal
et ici je me prends une inondation là un
ouragan
il y aura lancé plus compliqué et c'est
donc le modèle de climat à vous dire ce
qu'ils voient dans l'évolution du
système climatique dans les modèles les
plus avancés maintenant on a une
rétroaction entre la concentration et le
modèle de climat
alors un exemple si vous avez un climat
qui dérive de manière trop rapide et les
écosystèmes qui peuvent pas suivre une
partie des puits à co2 s'affaiblissent
les écosystèmes heures donc vous avez
moins de photosynthèse le co2 est moins
bien repris de l'atmosphère et du coup à
l'émission identique
vous avez la concentration qui
augmentent plus vite et bien ces
phénomènes d'asservissement sont pris en
compte dans les modèles les plus récents
par contre ce que même les modèles les
plus récents ne prennent pas en compte
et ne prendrons à mon avis jamais en
compte même ceux qui prétendent faire du
couplage avec l'économie c'est la
rétroaction sur les hypothèses d'entrée
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas un modèle
qui vous dit ah ben là le système a
commencé le système climatique a dérivé
tellement vite que c'est pas compatible
avec le fait que l'on maintienne le pib
actuel d'accord ça il ya aucun modèle de
climat qui vous raconte ça avec donc
cette particularité c'est tout cette
bizarrerie on va dire c'est que les
modèles enfin pardon les simulations qui
vous donne les résultats les plus
désagréables
en ce qui concerne le réchauffement
climatique vont avec les scénarios
d'émissions les plus importants qui dans
la façon dont ils sont rédigés
aujourd'hui vont aussi avec l'économie
qui se porte le mieux
donc on a quelque chose d'un peu
étonnant qu'ils aient quelque part que
plus le système climatique se dérègle
mieux l'économie se porte
c'est ça que vous avez en même temps
chronologiquement dans la façon dont
sont faits aujourd'hui dans son fait
aujourd'hui des simulations je répète ou
c est clair d'accord il faut les
émissions les plus importantes donc
l'économie dans les histoires racontées
qui va le mieux pour que le climat se
dérègle plus ce qui est une autre
manière de dire que le climat ne peut
jamais dans la façon dont les
simulations sont fait porter atteinte au
système économique
par construction
alors ce que seront les émissions
futures c'est évidemment impossible à
prédire
moi je ne sais pas prédire combien il y
aura deux hommes dans 40 ans je ne sais
pas prédire combien il y aura de pétrole
par personne et de gaz et de charbon par
personne et je sape à prédire combien
les gens mangeront de viande par
personne tout ce que je sais dire c'est
que si c'est extrêmement différent de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y
aura déjà eu une catastrophe qui sera
chargée de réguler rapidement le système
voilà c'est la seule chose que je sais
dire mais sinon je ne sais pas de primes
alors ce que les gens qui font des
simulations font c'est que comme ils
savent pas prédire et ben ils font des
scénarios dont qui prennent plusieurs
possibilités et dans ce que je vais vous
montrer à partir de maintenant les
résultats seront toujours sous condition
de l'hypothèse qu'on a prises en entrée
d'accord donc le sait quelque chose
encore une fois qui est essentiel il
faut toujours il faut bien comprendre
que les résultats que vous allez voir à
partir de maintenant sont toujours sous
conditions des émissions et du coup
puisque je pense que je ne donnerai pas
le sujet cette année une des raisons
pour lesquelles il est impossible de
prévoir de manière exacte les risques du
changement climatique c'est notamment
qu'il est impossible de prévoir de
manière exacte que ce sont les émissions
j'avais posé la question à votre pain
l'année dernière pourquoi s'il est
impossible de prévoir de manière exacte
les risques du changement climatique et
je pense qu'il y en a qu'un sur cinq
dans les copies qui est déjà réussi à
corriger qui m'a sorti que c'est parce
que les émissions n'était pas prévisible
alors alors ou bien les quatre autres
roupillait bien jour là il n'était pas
en forme mais voilà donc on peut pas
prévoir les émissions on ne pourra
jamais prévoir de manière exacte les
conséquences alors voici déjà ce que
donne une mise en perspective du premier
étage de la modélisation c'est à dire
passer des émissions à la concentration
alors encore une fois maintenant je
rappelle qu'on fait le chemin à l'envers
d'abord on a des airs cp et de là on
dérive les trajectoires possibles sur
les émissions c'est comme ça que ça se
fait aujourd'hui
vous avez ici donc une mise en
perspective de la concentration alors
pour ans en l'occurrence pour le plus
important d'entre eux ans et de co2 dans
l'air
celle que vous aviez avant que nous ne
fassions joujou avec les moteurs à
combustion interne et les machines à
vapeur
celle qui a commencé à se déformer
jusqu'à la fin du xxème siècle est ici
vous avez les évolutions possibles au
cours du 21e siècle mais vous voyez que
ces évolutions possibles sont très
différentes en fonction des scénarios
d'émissions alors le scénario bas
jusqu'à maintenant je le prends comme
des émissions qui reste constant alors
en fait il faudrait que je vous présente
les scénarios des du 1.5
on va dire en fait le scénario du 1.5 en
gros c'est ce qu'on a déjà émis
si on sait donc c'est pas les émissions
qui reste constante c'est des émissions
qui deviennent nul demain matin c'est ça
le scénario 1.5 des émissions qui reste
constante jusqu'à des émissions qui sont
très fortement augmenté alors jusqu'à
maintenant j'avais coutume d'appeler ça
mon scénario polonais de l'an 2000
pourquoi polonais de l'an 2000 parce que
le polonais et l'européen qui se
reposent encore aujourd'hui le plus sur
le charbon en proportion or ce qui reste
à extraire du sous sol
c'est avant tout du charbon est par
ailleurs de l'an 2000 parce que ça
correspond ce scénario a effectivement
la consommation de 10 milliards enfin à
10 milliards de terriens qui utiliserait
par personne la même quantité d'énergie
qu'un polonais d'aujourd'hui c'est pour
ça que je l'avais appelé comme ça et ça
permet un peu de se figurer en termes
socio économique ce que signifie un tel
scénario démission donc en fait ça veut
juste dire une humanité de 10 milliards
d'individus qui considère que ce qui
était ce qui est acceptable ce qui est
normal ce qui est standard on va dire
c'est de vivre comme un polonais de l'an
2000 si on a ça à la fois en termes de
consommation d'énergie et de
performances techniques
à ce moment on arrive à un scénario des
missions qui vous donne cette
concentration en co2 à la fin du 21e
siècle pour donner
une fois donc on a une évolution de la
concentration en co2 à ce moment on la
met dans un modèle de climat alors
modèles de climat c'est quoi c'est une
planète virtuelle
donc au lieu d'être flight simulator ces
climats de simulator et cette planète
virtuelle qui est donc un modèle
numérique qui fonctionne sur ordinateur
est nécessairement un modèle discret
parce que vous savez que même très
puissant les ordinateurs n'aime pas
l'infini tout ce qu'ils savent faire
c'est gérer un nombre fini d'opération
où un nombre fini de points wii
ensuite
on peut toujours faire des scénarios
pire j'ai aucun problème je dis juste
celui là en l'occurrence correspond un
polonais de l'an 2000 appliquée à dix
milliards d'individus
c'est moi qui choisis ça c'est pour
illustrer c'est parce que comme vous
vous avez encore aujourd'hui un niveau
de vie qui est supérieur à celui d'un
polonais est bien ce que je dis c'est
que ces 10 milliards de terriens à
veulent vivre un peu moins bien goût
voilà ce que ça donne comme scénarios
d'émissions enfin vous avec le niveau de
confort matériel que vous avez
aujourd'hui pour être plus précis voilà
ce que ça donne comme niveau d'émissions
et donc comme niveau de concentration
c'était pour illustrer sens donc je
disais un modèle de climat c'est une
représentation numérique de la planète
c'est un modèle est donc par
construction c'est quelque chose qui est
discret donc il ya des mailles alors la
façon dont ça fonctionne c'est que on
découpe tous les compartiments fluide de
la planète en boîte à chaussures
c'est à dire en parallélépipède enfin ou
presque parce qu'ils sont un peu courtes
alors ces départs à les pipettes pour
clooney ou pour personne ayant les pieds
très plat parce que typiquement la
longueur sur l'horizontale ces quelques
dizaines à 100 km il ya 100 km un ordre
de grandeur
par contre l'épaisseur sur la verticale
c'est plutôt de l'ordre de la centaine
de mètres donc c'est des pieds très très
plat mais sinon c'est ça l'idée 1 c'est
qu'on va découper l'atmosphère et
l'océan en boîte à chaussures et on va
en ce qui concerne le sol le représenter
par des miles a aussi qui ont des
propriétés des changes avec l'atmosphère
qui sont différentes selon qu'il s'agit
d'eau ou de terre à l'évidence ces
modèles on était sophistiqué au conte du
temps mais tous y reposent sur les
équations de bases de la physique est
alors un truc qui est important c'est
que ça peut paraître très étonnant au
début parce qu'on se dit tiens comme ça
qu'on a l'habitude de faire les
expériences mais un truc qui est très
important à savoir c'est que ce qu'on
regarde avec ses modèles c'est la façon
dont ils convergent avec des
concentrations en gaz à effet de serre
donné et on ne les entend dire ça ne
dépend pas de l'état initial avec lequel
on les paramètres dit autrement
ces modèles que la température moyenne
l'année zéro soit 15 16 ou 17 degrés
c'est pas le sujet en fait ce qu'on va
regarder c'est comment est-ce qu'ils
convergent au cours du temps avec ce
qu'on leur a donné comme comme évolution
sur les la quantité de gaz à effet de
serre comprise
enfin qui devrait passer donc ces
modèles ils sont améliorées au cours du
temps la première chose qu'ils qu'ils
ont fait c'est que la maia parce qu'en
fait il s'améliore à mesure que la
puissance informatique disponible
augmente
vous savez que traditionnellement les
organismes météo font partie des
acheteurs des supercalculateurs les gens
qui aiment bien les ordinateurs de très
grosses puissances
c'est les gens qui font de la météo et
en ce qui concerne les modèles de climat
et bien il tourne avec une partie
atmosphérique qui est exactement celle
de la météo alors cdma et moins fines
mais c'est les mêmes équations le les
quatre acronyme où les quatre sigle que
vous avez ici sont représentatifs des
quatre premiers rapports d'évaluation du
giec donc f pour first assessement
treport s seconde t shirt et comme on
avait déjà utilisé f pour faire 100
appareils utilisés f pour force
donc on a mis ailleurs 4 quand même je
vous ai dit que des fois qu'ils aient
des gens qui confondent s'est pas
complètement impossible
ce que vous voyez ces deux choses
d'abord c'est que la taille de la maille
a très nettement diminué et la deuxième
chose que vous voyez c'est qu'il ya du
relief qui est apparu c'est à dire que
initialement le sol était plat et en
fait ce qui était ce qui était
différencier c'était l'eau et la terre
et sur la terre vous aviez la végétation
et la terre non recouvertes qui était
différencier mais c'était pas
différencier au niveau du cycle du
carbone c'était différencier au niveau
de l'albédo surtout c'est à dire de
pouvoir de réflexion de la surface et
puis vous voyez qu'avec le temps on fait
apparaître du relief c'est à dire que
l'on fait apparaître une capacité à
différencier en altitude ce qui occupe
une maille 6 et de l'atmosphère ou si
c'est du simple on a également très
forte
oui
non non c'est lié au fait que sur le
premier os x est plat il ya un petit
machin à droite oui effectivement
si vous voulez enfin on va dire que ça
pas grand chose à voir avec un oui
effectivement à gauche vous avez du
relief pardon excusez moi oui non mais
c'est du relief qui est mal qui reste
très grossier vous avez raison là la
deuxième chose qui a eu lieu en ce qui
concerne les modèles c'est que au fur et
à mesure ils se sont complexifiées en ce
qui concerne les processus qui sont
prises en compte
donc le au moment du premier de la
première génération de modèles j'ai
envie de dire
il était essentiellement atmosphérique
et le reste des compartiments de la
planète n'apparaissait pas et donc les
échanges avec l'océan était part à
maîtriser par exemple c'est là qu'il
avait pas de dynamique il n'y avait pas
de dynamique océanique l'océan était vue
comme une surface des changes avec la
planète et les échanges étaient part à
maîtriser et puis au fur et à mesure que
les générations de modèles avance vous
vous mettez à avoir de plus en plus deux
compartiments qui apparaissent donc vous
avez un océan vous avez de la végétation
l'océan se met à devenir dynamique vous
avez les aérosols et maintenant dans les
modèles les plus récents
vous avez l'essentiel de ce qui se passe
dans l'atmosphère enfin dans
l'atmosphère sur la terre plus
exactement donc dans l'atmosphère et
dans l'océan
voyez évidemment la couverture nuageuse
qui est apparue maintenant il ya la
chevillette moss féerique vous avez
cycle du carbone etc
donc vous avez l'essentiel des grands
processus qui sont qui sont représentés
quelque chose qui est intéressant à
noter soit dit en passant c'est que
l'amélioration de ses modèles à aucun
moment n'a jamais changé
fondamentalement les ordres de grandeur
sur l'élévation de température qui
résulte d'une augmentation données de la
concentration en co2 dans l'atmosphère
tout simplement parce que cette
élévation de température
résulte au premier ordre de la quantité
d'énergie supplémentaire qui est envoyé
vers le sol par un supplément d effet de
serre que ça ça relève d'un processus
physiques assez bien compris
d'absorption réémission par un gaz
d'accord et que une fois que vous avez
la quantité d'énergie totale qui
retourne au sol et que vous savez faire
le split entre ce qui est absorbé par
l'océan et qui est absorbé par le sol au
premier ordre
vous avez assez facilement votre
élévation de température du sol donc le
la raison pour laquelle donc la
sophistication des modèles elle permet
de mieux approcher un certain nombre de
phénomènes locaux notamment elle permet
d'améliorer la résolution spatiale
en ce qui concerne ce qui va se passer
par contre elle n'a pas changé au
premier ordre
j'insiste les conséquences globales j'ai
envie de dire de ce qui va de ce qui va
se passer et notamment l'élévation de
température moyenne qui représente
l'élévation de la quantité d'énergie
contenue dans le système les modèles les
modèles climatiques
comme tous les modèles quand ils sont
utilisés par des gens qui savent à peu
près ce qu'ils font une des choses la
première chose en fait qu'on fait une
fois qu'on les a mis au point ces de les
tester sur le passé quand vous avez un
modèle
la première chose que vous faites pour
vérifier que ça marche c'est de le
confronter à ce qui s'est passé
auparavant
alors soit dit en passant il n'y a pas
un modèle économique qui passe la rampe
de genre de trucs sauf si vous modifiez
les paramètres année après année pour
être sûr que ça colle mais sinon ça
marche pas en ce qui concerne les
modèles physiques
c'est exactement comme ça qu'ils sont
calibrés et donc c'est exactement comme
ça qu'ils sont cons calibre les modèles
de climat ce que vous voyez ici c'est
donc tout graphique du giec il ya
énormément d'informations
c'est la façon dont un ensemble de
modèles de mémoire y en a une vingtaine
là dedans se confronte à ce qui a été
observé en ce qui concerne l'évolution
des températures
donc en ce qui concerne l'évolution des
températures
vous avez sur chacun des graphiques qui
représente soit une zone ici soit
l'ensemble du monde des terres émergées
ou des océans en bas eh bien vous avez
ce que vous raconte les modèles quand on
les laisse évoluer avec une évolution
des gaz à effet de serre qui a été et ce
qu'elle est en rose
vous avez en noir ce qu on vraiment
donné les relevés de température
vous voyez partout et donc ce que vous
voyez c'est que à quelques anomalies
près à cette époque là par exemple sur
l'océan
eh bien il ya et donc il se répète un
peu sur le qui passe un peu sur le
global là et bien vous avez quelque
chose qui des modèles vous reproduisent
assez bien la tendance générale sur la
variation des températures sur la
période alors les mêmes modélisateurs se
sont amusés à regarder ce qu aurait
donné le modèle qui reproduit ce qui
s'est passé si les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre n'avait pas augmenté et à
ce moment ça vous donne la courbe bleue
enfin vous également l' enveloppe bleue
donc l' enveloppe bleue celle enveloppe
de toutes les simulations qui sont
faites avec des modèles de climat dans
un monde virtuel où les hommes n'ont pas
émis de gaz à effet de serre et à ce
moment ce que vous voyez c'est que
globalement les températures restent à
peu près constante
le système est à peu près stable et
alors que ce quand vous mettez les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
système dérive voilà donc ce genre de ce
genre de test est quelque chose qui est
absolument indispensable pour accorder
de la crédibilité à ces outils
numériques pour ceux qui vont raconter
pour plus tard je voulais pas à mener
aujourd'hui mais vous trouvez sur
internet c'est pour ceux d'entre vous
qui vont chercher des simulations alors
là pour le coup en temps réel de ses
modèles de climat qui simule la terre
vue de l'atmosphère et donc vous il ya
une comparaison entre des images
satellites réel bas côté et une
représentation avec un modèle numérique
de l'autre et quand vous comparez les
deux fait le test avec quelqu'un en
double aveugle
en général les gens savent pas quoi ça
pas dire lequel est lequel d'accord
aujourd'hui il ya également une qualité
de représentation extrêmement fine en ce
qui concerne la capacité de ces modèles
a représenté le
qu'est ce que je veux dire visuellement
le système on va donc parler d'avenir
avec ses modèles une fois qu'ils ont été
capables de retracer le passé ce que
vous avez ici c'est à nouveau un
graphique qui est issu du dernier enfin
oui du dernier gros rapports du giec de
la banda des parts en 2007 à 2013
mais ça n'a pas tellement changé dans le
dernier l'intérêt de ce graphique c'est
que ça vous discrimine très précisément
la manière dont la température peut
évoluer en fonction du scénario
démission c'est ça leur l'idée qu'il
faut qu'il faut avoir en tête
donc ce que vous voyez ici c'est
l'évolution de la température sur le
xxème siècle vous constatez que
xxème siècle c'est déjà une fraction de
degrés et qui a été gagné et puis la
façon dont la température évolue à
l'avenir en fonction de l'hypothèse
qu'on fait sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre alors l'hypothèse la plus
basse dans ces simulations c'est la
concentration reste constante
ce qui veut dire que en gros les
émissions se mettent à décroître très
très rapidement à partir de demain matin
et elles deviennent nul bien avant la
fin du siècle donc là effectivement vous
voyez que contient les 1,5 degrés donc
là vous avez un degré 1
on était parti à peu près de là donc on
tient les 1,5 degrés donc dit autrement
pour tenir les 1,5 degré ça veut dire
qu'ils font que les émissions se mettent
à diminuer très vite à partir de demain
et soit nul bien avant la fin du siècle
c'est ça que ça veut dire de tenir les
25 degrés
et on n'est pas parti pour le faire
après vous avez ici un scénario dans
lequel on garde des émissions constante
en brousse c'est ça le scénario lorsque
vous voyez ici c'est que c'est un
scénario dans lequel on gagne 2 degrés
par rapport à 1990 que vous avez ici
mais on en gagne déjà quasiment 3 par
rapport à l'ère préindustrielle donc ce
que vous avez là c'est un scénario qui
est quasiment 3 degrés ce que vous voyez
ici celle enveloppe pour ce scénario de
toutes les simulations de l' enveloppe
de tout et de tous les modèles dit
autrement les vingt modèles qui sont
utilisés avec ce même scénario le plus
conservateur vous dis on va gagner un
degré par rapport à 1990 est le plus
pessimiste vous dis on va gagner 3
degrés par rapport à 1990 ce que vous
dis donc ce graphique c'est qu'ils
restent une variabilité liées aux
hypothèses qu'on a fait dans le modèle
parce que même vague entre tous les
modèles vous avez pas exactement les
mêmes options qui sont prises pour la
représentation d'un certain nombre de
processus
ou plus exactement pour les valeurs
prises pour les paramètres ou les
conditions aux limites d'un certain
nombre de processus parce que vous avez
des trucs qui reste par à maîtriser là
dedans donc en fonction du modèle
évidemment les paramètres on essaye de
les ajuster pardon en fonction des
observations passées c'est comme ça
qu'on essaye de recalibrer le modèle en
permanence et donc en fonction du modèle
qui est utilisé vous voyez que vous avez
quand même une part d'erreur qui est de
l'ordre de 2 degrés sur ce scénario là
sur l'élévation de température que vous
avez à l'arrivée donc on n'est pas tout
à fait dans l'épaisseur du trait parce
que vous allez voir que les conséquences
en ce qui concerne
enfin les conséquences liées au
changement climatique c'est pas du tout
les mêmes à +1 et à +3 le scénario
intermédiaire ici est un scénario qui
est considéré comme un scénario charbon
au moins dans mon jargon c'est à dire
que les émissions double et alors là
vous voyez toujours pareil ce qui
correspond à ce scénario est là et donc
dans ce scénario là dans la version
basse on n'est qu'à 5 mai dans la
version haute on est à plus de 4 alors
très souvent il ya une erreur qu'ils
aient fait en face de ce genre
d'incertitude qui est de se dire ah bah
si subsiste une grande incertitude sur
le fait qu on court un grand danger
à ce moment je vais attendre d'en savoir
plus pour être sûr que vraiment c'est un
grand danger alors parallèle que je vais
prendre c'est si un de vos copains un
jour il ya beaucoup bu vous demande de
traverser les champs elysées à 5 heures
du matin a les yeux bruns et les yeux
bandés
je pense qu'il ya une grande incertitude
sur le fait que vous allez mourir ou pas
pas complètement sûr que vous allez le
faire
donc en fait une grande incertitude
c'est représentatif au contraire un
grand risque si il ya une grande
incertitude
ça veut dire que je ne suis pas capable
de vous donner une borne supérieure sur
ce que vous risquez d'accord donc l'idée
qu'une grande incertitude c'est une
grande police d'assurance qui signifie
qu'il est urgent de ne rien faire est
l'exact inverse de la conclusion qu'il
faut tirer une grande incertitude
c'est un grand risque c'est un très
grand risque et enfin mon scénario donc
polonais est un scénario dont vous voyez
que il peut nous emmener au delà de 6
degrés
avec la génération de modèles qui
étaient utilisés à cette époque là alors
maintenant on a coutume de dire que
c'est plutôt 5
mais enfin ça change pas beaucoup les
conclusions que vous allez avoir
derrière vous comprenez donc là que vous
avez une dispersion
encore une fois lié au modèle qu'on
utilise en fonction de la valeur pour un
même scénario
une autre manière de présenter la même
chose c'est que quand on fait une
simulation en fait on peut également
faire une simulation on peut faire deux
choses en fait on peut regarder oui
[Musique]
non me now c'est à partir de 18h50 et
donc il y en a déjà un qui a été
embarqué est donc en gros pour qu'on se
libère en gros il faut que les émissions
deviennent nul demain matin en eau
voilà en ce qui concerne pas dans la
façon de comprendre ça je vais vous le
montrer autrement pour un même modèle
vous pouvez faire plusieurs simulations
avec des petits changements de
paramètres dans le modèle est évidemment
à chaque fois ça va vous donner une
valeur un peu différente donc vous allez
avoir une distribution des résultats et
vous considérez que la valeur que vous
allez retenir c'est le sommet de votre
gaussienne si jamais vos résultats sont
distribuées de façon à peu près normale
ou bien vous pouvez aussi considéré que
pour une famille de modèles vous allez
regarder les sommets des gaussienne pour
chacun des modèles et faire une moyenne
de tout ça est considéré que c'est ça
que vous allez retenir comme valeur pour
la simulation multi modèle à ce que l'on
appelle multi ensemble en anglais donc
en fait ce qu'il faut comprendre avec
ces histoires de simulation c'est une
autre manière de dire exactement la même
chose c'est que quand on vous dit
pour tels scénarios d'émissions la
valeur le réchauffement qu'on obtient
derrière et de temps en fait il faut
comprendre que ce temps c'est la valeur
la plus probable d'une distribution qui
ressemble à une normale donc ça n'est
pas une façon de garantir que ça ne peut
pas être plus c'est clair ça n'est pas
une façon de garantir que ça ne peut pas
être plus
ce qui est intéressant avec l'élévation
de température que nous allons avoir ou
ce qui est indispensable plus exactement
pas seulement un indice intéressant
c'est de confronter sa au passé pourquoi
imaginons que je prenne un être vivant
et que je vous dise cet être vivant je
vais augmenter sa température de 4
degrés alors vous allez me dire ah j'ai
oublié pas dont je vous demande est-ce
que c'est ennuyeux ou est ce que ce
n'est pas ennuyeux et ben je vais vous
dire ça dépend si vous prenez un poisson
rouge
ceux d'entre vous qui auront un jour des
enfants aux enfants réclamant peut-être
un jour un poisson rouge moment où vous
découvrirez que poisson rouge
il a besoin d'être emmenés en vacances
etc et donc vous êtes pressés que le
poisson rouge meurent parce que comme ça
que vous êtes débarrassé les
emmerdements
alors vous avez payé pour faire mourir
le poisson rouge de lui donner de l'eau
un peu plus froide un peu plus chaude
etc
vous voyez que le poisson rouge se porte
comme un charme à votre votre grand
désespoir pourquoi sarah parce que le
poisson rouge et d'un animal à poissons
animal pardon à sang froid et donc le
poisson rouge voulu infliger une
élévation de quatre degrés de l'eau dans
laquelle ils se promènent il s'en fout
complètement
qu'ils continuent à être là et bien là
et à devoir partir ex mc royaume si vous
infligez donc à certains animaux une
variation de leur température interne de
4 degrés ça leur fait pardonnez moi
l'expression ni chaud ni froid donc
c'est vraiment pas grave si je prends un
animal à sang chaud vous par exemple et
que je vous inflige une variation de
votre température interne de 4 degrés il
suffit que j'attendais un peu et vous
êtes mort donc 4 degrés en plus
est-ce que c'est grave docteur pour le
système climatique la réponse est
exactement la même
ça dépend de la variation spontanée du
système quand il est livré à lui-même
si on réalise que le système livré à
lui-même il varie de 4 degrés d'une
semaine sur l'autre
c'est vraiment pas grave que l'action
des hommes provoque un réchauffement de
4 degrés puisque ça rentre dans la
variabilité naturelle du système
or on s'en fiche complètement d'induire
par contre si la variabilité naturelle
du système n'est pas de 4° tous les
quatre matins à ce moment ça devient
très ennuyeux parce que ça veut dire
qu'on inflige une déstabilisation qui
est inédite et donc il y aura des
conséquences qui seront inédites alors
pour répondre à la question en ce qui
concerne le système climatique il faut
être capable de reconstituer la manière
dont il a varié dans le passé
et donc il ya tout une discipline
maintenant de la science qui s'appelle
la paléoclimatologie qui sert à ça c'est
à dire qui sert à reconstituer les
variations de température du passé il ya
deux grandes familles de techniques pour
faire ça mais où trois grandes familles
plus exactement et à chaque fois c'est
la science du trou pour faire des trous
je n'ai pas fermé à une première manière
de faire des trous c'est de faire des
trous dans les arbres et si possible
dans les arbres très vieux et comme ça
on va mesurer l'épaisseur et la dureté
des cernes d'arbres qui s'agrège année
après année dans le tronc alors est ce
que vous savez quel est l'âge du plus
vieil arbre vivant aujourd'hui 2000
qui dit mieux sept cents qui dit mieux
c'est encore un peu plus que ça c'est
7000 il ya un pain alors cessé d arbres
qui est vive en général dans des zones
qui sont extrêmement limite pour la vie
donc c'est comme la neige en antarctique
quoi c'est des trucs qui s'accroissent
extrêmement peu tous les ans un
métabolisme très très ralenti et je
crois que c'est un pain de californie
dans une zone semi désertique donc dans
cette dans ce trou là on peut aller
faire des trous et donc on a sept
milandes archives climatique alors le
problème c'est qu'on n'a pas des archis
global on a une archive climatique
là où pousse l'arbre alors qu'est ce
qu'elle vous donne c'est par ailleurs là
avec nous pas en hiver donc cette
archive climatique qu'est ce qu'elles
vous donnent elles vous donnent les
températures on est capable avec sa de
reconstituer les températures et les
précipitations de la saison de pousse
c'est à dire printemps été mais de là on
a déjà un proxy pour voir comment évolue
le système climatique dans son ensemble
sur l'année les arbres vous aurez
remarqué comme moi que il en pousse pas
beaucoup sur l'eau donc cette méthode là
elle marche bien pour reconstituer les
températures terrestres
donc dès que vous avez accès à des
arbres ou à des troncs d'arbre
fossilisée que vous êtes capable de
dater correctement eh bien vous avez
accès à une technique qui s'appelle la
dendrochronologie qui vous permet de
reconstituer les températures du passé à
nouveau ces températures du passé se
reconstitue avec une modélisation qui
permet de passer des données
d'observation l'épaisseur et la dureté
des cernes d'arbres
à une température observée qu'une
température existantes plus exactement
et vous avez les modèles qui permettent
de faire ça on une à nouveau un
paramétrage propres de telle sorte que
chaque chercheur qui fait ce genre de
truc qui fait ce genre de l'analyse
publie ses propres résultats alors vous
avez ici une compilation qui a été
publié dans le rapport du giec de 2007
dans laquelle vous avez tous les auteurs
qui sont là qui ont chacun publié une
reconstitution d'une reconstitution
pardon des températures de l'hémisphère
nord parce que c'est le plus équipé on
va dire en terres émergées sur le
dernier millénaire alors ce que vous
voyez sur le dernier millénaire c'est
qu'il ya deux points de convergence de
ces analyses
la première c'est que tous s'y disent au
moment de l'an mil à peu près il a fait
un peu plus chaud qu'au reste du
millénaire et alors c'est ce un peu plus
chaud aux alentours de l'an mil est
connue sous le nom de l'optimum médiéval
alors il ya un truc qui vous
intéresseraient avant l'optimum médiéval
s'exhaler du vin en angleterre donc je
pense que le vin ça vous intéresse
beaucoup et dans les autres conséquences
que on a eu à ce moment là c'est que les
vikings ont sorti leurs prospectus
publicitaires et on dit allez donc au
groenland s'est ouvert et en fait
greenland groenland
alors qu'il fait ou froid ça veut dire
père verte
il ya dans l'histoire qui est une
histoire qui souvent enfourché par les
climato-sceptiques pour dire 'regardez
climat varie naturellement il ya eu un
moment où le voir une lande est ouvert
et c'est donc lors landes et épate
ouvert il ya bilan il y avait la même
calotte glaciaire qu'aujourd'hui sur le
groenland
par contre vous avez une frange du
groenland où vous n'avez pas de glace
c'est là soit dit en passant qui habite
quelques inuits eskimos etc vous avez
quelques quelques bancs au jeu et sur
ces endroits qui était dépourvu de glace
ya bilan comme aujourd'hui la saison de
pousse de l'herbe était un peu plus
longue qu'aujourd'hui et donc on
soupçonne les vikings de s'être
débarrassé de quelques personnes qu'ils
avaient plus envie de voir les
expédients là bas avec troupeau et
femmes et enfants
ou vous pouvez lire l'histoire dans le
bouquin de jared diamond qui s'appelle
l'effondrement collapse alors il ya un
certain nombre de trucs qui sont
discutables dans son bouquin mais ça par
contre c'est assez bien raconté je pense
que c'est assez juste
donc on a envoyé 5000 vikings là bas
avec leurs troupeaux et puis au moment
où le climat s'est refroidie après
l'optimum médiéval voyez là et bien là
saison de pousse de l'herbe à diminuer
les vaches sont mortes et les vikings
avec parce que ils n'ont pas voulu se
mettre à manger du phoque
il aimait passer à culturellement voilà
donc les modèles convergent pour faire
les analyses convergent pour vous dire
ça oui qu'après ça se refroidit là on
est à quelque chose qui s'appelle le
petit âge glaciaire en europe les canaux
de bruges jelle totalement l'hiver on se
pèle de froid la marquise de sévigné à
lille du feu au mois d'août enfin bref
c'est le bagne et c soit dit en passant
à ce moment là qu'a lieu la révolution
française vous savez que la révolution
française est née après une grande
famine qui a eu en france qui a fait
entre 500 et 1000 morts et un million de
morts
et donc c'est une époque où les récoltes
sont pas bonnes
et donc ça a déclenché des troubles
parce que les gens n'aiment pas avoir le
ventre vide ce que vous voyez également
en troisième
convergence de tous ces trucs là c'est
que à partir du début de l'époque
industrielle craquent toutes les
analyses vous disent que ça se met à
monter rapidement donc la première
conclusion qu'on arrive à tirer de cette
analyse là à l'échelle du millénaire
c'est qu'on est déjà ici dans un
déplacement de température qui est
totalement hors tendance qui va beaucoup
plus vite que toutes tendances que vous
pouvez dégager la super bien de tendance
je parle pas de variation annuelle de
toutes tendances que vous pouvez dégager
là dessus alors après on peut remonter
plus loin dans le temps on peut remonter
on peut remonter j'avoue mon travail
après mais on peut remonter là sur ce
graphique là jusqu'à 60 millions
d'années
et alors si on regarde à 60 millions
ce qu'on voit c'est que depuis cette
époque le climat alors on fait attention
à l'instant présent et ici l'instant
passée et là on voit que ce qui s'est
passé est globalement un lent
refroidissement du système climatique et
selon refroidissement du système petit
but
pardon est notamment allé avec une
diminution importante de la quantité de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
donc à des échelles de temps très très
longue effectivement le climat a plutôt
eu tendance à se refroidir
ce que vous voyez également c'est que il
ya longtemps le climat a pu être
quasiment 10 degrés plus chaud
qu'aujourd'hui
donc le fait que le climat soit plus
chaud qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
nécessairement quelque chose qui est une
première dans l'histoire planétaire par
contre ce qui est une première dans
l'histoire planétaire et c'est ça qu'on
va détailler à partir de maintenant
c'est une variation de cette ampleur
appliqué à une humanité sédentaires de 7
milliards de bons hommes ou 10 milliards
de bons hommes ça c'est nouveau et s'il
ya eu des variations de grande ampleur
dans le passé à aucun moment en tout cas
en ce qui nous concerne
elles n'ont empêché notre espèce de
develop de se développer puisqu'on est
là
par contre entre ne pas porter atteinte
à l'espèce et ne portait atteinte à
aucun représentant de l'espèce il ya une
petite différence
dit autrement si le changement
climatique en cours ne laisse que 5
millions de bons jeunes survivants s'est
largement
assez pour assurer la perpétuation de
l'espèce ça ne pose pas de problème pour
la perpétuation de l'espèce
donc là le sujet on va voir à partir de
maintenant c'est patent est ce que les
autres vont passer à travers ça je peux
vous déjà donnés je peux déjà vous allez
raconte sa réponse est oui c'est est ce
qu'on peut avoir une idée de dans
quelles conditions et combien d'entre
eux et ça c'est des questions qui
seraient ce des questions ouvertes
je vais introduire maintenant une
variation de température plus récente
que celle qui s'est passé il ya 65
millions d'années
avec cette petite carte qui représente
enfin deux cartes qui représente
l'europe
vous avez ici une représentation
schématique des écosystèmes qui sont
donc le reflet du système climatique car
le reflet du système climatique c'est
les écosystèmes installer les
écosystèmes installés en europe
aujourd'hui si on ne le supprime pas
pour faire alors essentiellement des
chants des routes des ponts des voies de
chemin de fer des usines et l'école des
mines
donc si on ne supprime pas les
écosystèmes pour faire tout ça on a en
europe essentiellement des forêts ça
veut dire que le climat est suffisamment
humide pour qu'ils poussent des gros
espèces végétales et que par ailleurs il
est ni trop froid ni trop chaud pour ne
pas que le métabolisme de ces espèces
soient gênés voilà à quoi ressemble
l'europe ya vingt mille ans alors il ya
vingt mille ans dans les évolutions du
quaternaire
nous sommes au coeur de la dernière ère
glaciaire donc il fait beaucoup plus
froid qu'aujourd'hui sinon on ne serait
pas en aire glaciaire
après vous allez voir de combien et
comme il fait beaucoup plus froid
qu'aujourd'hui le paysage de la planète
et pas du tout le même et le paysage de
l'europe n'est pas du tout le même
la première chose que vous pouvez voir
ici c'est que vous oubliez à se méfier
des suédois puisque il n'y a pas de
suédois
il n'y a pas de d'anouar il n'y a pas
deux finlandais il ya même pas de nord
allemand et il n'y a pas des causses est
donc bonne nouvelle pour les joueurs de
rugby tous et bolt ou tous ces braves
gens sont sous la glace vous avez une
énorme calotte de trois kilomètres
d'épaisseur qui recouvre la totalité de
la scandinavie alors pour ceux d'entre
vous qui les aime bien
il n'ya pas non plus de québécois
puisque la totalité du canada est aussi
sous la glace qui a pas de sables
bitumineux bonne nouvelle vous avez une
énorme calotte de glace encore plus
grosse que celle qui est posé sur la
scandinavie qui est posée sur le canal à
cette glace est constituée d'eau je ne
veux rien dire que vous êtes savez ça et
cette eau il a bien fallu la prend
quelque part alors il ya manifestement
pas assez d'eau ni dans les lacs ni dans
les rivières ni dans l'atmosphère pour
faire autant de glaces le seul endroit
où vous pouvez prendre toute cette eau
pour faire toute cette glace c'est la
mer et comme la mère est une grande
baignoire dans le fond n'a pas varié et
bien si vous prenez de l'eau pour faire
toute cette glace le niveau de l'eau
baisse et le niveau de l'eau est plus
bas de 120 mètres donc il n'y a pas de
course de l'edhec non plus puisqu'il
n'ya pas de manche or dans vous oubliez
le sponsoring pour aller faire de la
voile vous pouvez enfin faire des
problèmes sérieux dans parlons donc le
point bas de la manche aujourd'hui ses
114 m comme le niveau de l'eau est plus
bas de 120 plus de manches
pour ceux d'entre vous qui en ont
entendu parler on peut rentrer dans la
grotte cosquer à pied sec
je sais pas si vous savez où la grotte
cosquer grotte cosquer est une grotte
dont l'entrée est aujourd'hui immergé et
qui se trouve en méditerranée c'est à
dire qu'il faut descendre à 30 mètres
sous le niveau de l'eau pour rentrer
dans la grotte
alors vous avez un boyau ascendant et la
grotte est préservé elle est à
l'intérieur vous avez des peintures etc
comme à l'asco cette grotte aujourd'hui
l'entrée est immergé ça veut bien dire
que à l'époque où elle était habitée ça
veut dire qu'on pourra y est entré à
pied c'est qui fait seulement les hommes
préhistoriques n'avait pas de scaphandre
autonome et donc ça veut dire que le
niveau de l'eau était beaucoup plus bas
le climat est beaucoup plus froid
donc il y a beaucoup moins d'évaporation
donc il est beaucoup plus sec et dans ce
climat beaucoup plus froid et beaucoup
plus sec
la végétation installés en europe
ressemblent à ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui au nord de la sibérie
donc c'est pas très grave d'accord on
parlait pas de
les chatoyant champs de blé
d'aujourd'hui et la chatoyante forêt de
fontainebleau ne sont pas vraiment là et
dans ce genre d'écosystèmes on arrive à
faire vivre cent mille bon homme c'est à
dire 100 mille animaux en bout de chaîne
alimentaire
c'est à peu près la population humaine à
l'époque donc vous voyez c'est même pas
le nombre d'étudiants classe prépa je
crois enfin en tout cas c'est sûrement
pas le nombre d'étudiants en grandes
écoles tout court
donc vous voyez c'est un petit effectif
la population française à cette époque
donc à gauche
là l'europe en aire glaciaire à droite
l'europe d'aujourd'hui
donc je le répète quand on passe du
paysage de gauche au paysage de droite
j'ai un réchauffement climatique on est
d'accord et bien ce réchauffement
historiquement ces 5 degrés en cinq à
dix mille ans c'est juste ça donc on a
un précédent historique de quelques
degrés de réchauffement en valeur
absolue et vous voyez le genre de choses
que ça produit en ce qui concerne le
paysage donc une autre manière de dire
ça c'est que la variabilité naturelle du
système n'est pas du tout à l'échelle de
ce que nous sommes en train de
déclencher aujourd'hui d'accord donc le
beau parallèle c'est pas le poisson
rouge qui va résister à tous c'est bien
vous qui ne résistait pas à une et les
variations de quelques degrés de votre
température interne
pourvu que je la prolonge suffisamment
longtemps c'est bien ça le bon parallèle
alors si je met en perspective
maintenant ce qui s'est passé aux
derniers millénaires ce qui s'est passé
aux derniers siècles et ce qui pourrait
se passer à l'avenir voilà à quoi ça
ressemble ici vous avez la
reconstitution à partir de là d'un gros
chronologie comme je le disais tout à
l'heure essentiellement de la
température du siècle passé
donc ça s'est essentiellement fait avec
des analyses à partir de 1860
vous avez banon alors j'ai le commenter
vous avez
une mesure directe de l'élévation de
température de la planète
question pourquoi est ce qu'on n'a pas
fait ça avant 1860 pour être qu'avant
dit gyan 60 oui non beaucoup plus simple
que ça
et en particulier avec quoi on mesure
une température avec un thermomètre de
quand date l'invention du thermomètre
non quatorze 192
sauf que en 14 192 vous avez un
thermomètre est ce que vous mesurez la
température en tout point du globe avec
un thermomètre
non c'est un peu compliqué donc il en
faut beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup des
thermomètres pour commencer à mesurer la
température en tout point du globe
par ailleurs de quoi est faite la
surface terrestre en majorité d'eau
est-ce que vous avez beaucoup de villes
et beaucoup de chants à la surface de
l'océan n'ont pas beaucoup elle donc qu
est-ce que vous avez une grosse
population et donc beaucoup de
thermomètre à la surface de l'océan
non vous avez quand même des
thermomètres à la surface de l'océan
où ça
pardon sur les bateaux absolument vous
avez depuis que vous avez des moteurs et
des machines à vapeur vous avez
notamment des thermomètres en entrée de
prise d'eau pour mesurer la température
de l'eau parce que ça vous sert à régler
les machines et même avant il arrivait
qu'on fasse des prélèvements etc
sauf que ces prélèvements ne sont faits
que sur les routes commerciales parce
que les bateaux se balade pour
transporter des marchandises
s'il commence à faire du tourisme leur
patron les engueuler et donc il faut
attendre que vous ayez suffisamment de
routes commerciales à la surface de la
planète pour qu'on considère que les
températures mesurées dans l'océan sont
représentatives de la température de
l'eau et donc avoir suffisamment de
thermomètre sur les terres émergées et
suffisamment de thermomètre sur les
bateaux qui se balade pour considérer
qu'on a quelque chose qui commence à
ressembler à un échantillonnage
représentatif
on considère que avant 1860 c'est pas le
cas donc à partir de 1860
on est capable de proposer une mesure
instrumental de la moyenne planétaire we
elle est représentative de la
température de l'eau là où vous passez
c'est pas le sillage du bateau c'est pas
la traînée du bateau qui va réchauffer
l'eau au point que ça perturbe la mesure
est donc vous avez en perspective ici je
le répète trois températures mesurées de
manière différente et à des époques
différentes donc là analyse la
instrumental directement et des
thermomètres et la modéliser donc il n'y
a plus de thermomètre on rentre dans la
modélisation c'est la modélisation de ce
qui se passe plus tard est ce que vous
voyez sans l'ombre d'une commandite
d'une discussion possible
sur ce graphique c'est que la variation
de température à venir est quelque chose
qui est sans commune mesure
quel que soit le scénario retenu avec la
variabilité naturelle du système
donc même à 2 degrés c'est ça la con
c'est que la chorale la conséquence
enfin la conclusion qu'il faut avoir en
tête
même à 2 degrés nous allons voir une
quantité considérable de
dysfonctionnement dans le système qui
n'existait pas jusqu'à maintenant
même à 2 degrés si on met ça sur en fait
voilà la courbe qui vous donne la
variation du système sur des échelles de
temps
on va dire depuis le dernier maximum
glaciaire donc ici vous avez la
reconstruction de la température du
passé avec des analyses
alors quand on est à l'échelle de la
dizaine de milliers d'années c'est plus
les cernes d'arbres qu'on utilise
c'est la reconstruction avec les
isotopes de l'oxygène et de l'hydrogène
dans les calottes glaciaires c'est ça
dont j'ai parlé la dernière fois vous
voyez ici que la température au début de
l'holocène étaient légèrement
supérieures à ce qu'elles étaient
derrière ça c'est ce qu'on a déjà fait
aujourd'hui et ça à l'échelle 1 c'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire dans le siècle qui
vient donc vous voyez que manifestement
l'image du mur est assez bonne une
élévation de quelques degrés en un
siècle
ça ressemble plus au mur qu à une
promenade de santé
ça va vraiment provoquer des
dysfonctionnements majeurs un peu
partout dans le système on va rentrer un
peu dans le détail derrière quelque
chose qui est important à garder en
mémoire c'est que cette élévation de
température déjà en cours et qui va
s'accélérer
de temps en temps elle oui
on
oui
c'est 200 l'occurrence le rayonnement
solaire c'est plutôt de 130 l'effet de
serre c'est plutôt cent soixante dix
mais tout ça c'est de cette heure devant
de rui 2,5 et oui madame ça suffit
d'abord c'est 2,5 aujourd'hui vous dire
que ça augmente avec le temps et par
exemple on verra un peu plus tard les ce
qu'on appelle les rcp représentative
concentre la chaîne favorise en fait le
nombre que vous avez derrière représente
le forçage radiatif en 2100 donc le rcp
4 5 c 4 5 watts par mètre carré en 2006
en tant qu'ils augmentent dans dans
l'est dans les simulations évident avec
le temps et par ailleurs il faut voir
que en ordre de grandeur
alors c'est vraiment un ordre de
grandeur 1% d'augmentation de l'effet de
serre c'est un degré en plus en eau dont
4 % d'augmentation ces quatre degrés ont
beau je dis bien en gros parce que c'est
le processus est pas du tout linéaire
mais bon ça c'est les ordres vendeurs
oui j zay l'élévation de température au
sol
de temps en temps elle fait une petite
pause
cette petite pause elle ne remet pas en
cause le ce qui se passe tout simplement
parce que il ya une petite illusion
d'optique dans cette histoire beaucoup
de gens considèrent que ce qui est
représentatif de ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est l'élévation de température
de l'atmosphère
alors en fait l'élévation de température
de l'atmosphère c'est la partie émergée
de l'iceberg
parce que ce que vous montre ce
diagramme sait où va le supplément
d'énergie qui vient du supplément
d'effet de serre et ce supplément
d'énergie
ce que vous voyez de sueur sur cette
image c'est que plus de 90% en fait
réchauffe non pas l'atmosphère mais
l'océan c'est l'océan et je vous l'avais
déjà dit précédemment qui pilotent
l'inertie du système à l'échelle de
temps qui nous intéresse ici
or il suffit que le switch qui répartit
l'énergie entre l'océan et l'atmosphère
change un peu une année donnée par
exemple vous avez une circulation dans
fin la circulation qui enfouit la
chaleur dans l'océan
il suffit qu'elles soient un peu plus
actives ou au contraire un peu plus
faible et à ce moment vous allez avoir
ou bien une accélération de la
température de surface ou au contraire
un ralentissement de l'élévation voire
un léger refroidissement de la
température de surface une année donnée
la variabilité de la température
atmosphérique
elle dépend notamment de ce processus
d'enfouissement de la chaleur dans
l'océan qui peut connaître des petites
variations à cause de petites variations
de la circulation océanique
ça ne fait absolument pas obstacle au
fait que globalement le système
emmagasinent de plus en plus d'énergie
mais si cette énergie elle est dans une
couche intermédiaire de l'océan par
exemple vous en voyez pas la traduction
dans la température de surface oui
le l'échangé d'énergie il fait comment
ah ils dépendent on verra après il
dépend de la circulation océanique à
large échelle vous avez des processus
convectifs dans l'océan
et quand l'eau qui était en surface
passe en profondeur l enfoui avec elle
la chaleur qu'elle emporte
enfin l emporte avec elle la chaleur
corps et elle est remplacée en surface
par de l'eau un peu plus froide qui
vient des profondeurs
donc il suffit que ce mouvement
s'accélère ou ralentissent un peu et en
gros vous avez un processus
d'enfouissement de la chaleur de la
surface vers les profondeurs qui
s'accélère ou qui est au contraire
ralenti un peu et donc ça c'est un
élément qui pilote la température de
surface
on va maintenant commencer à regarder
les impacts un peu plus détaillée de
trucs qu'il faut avoir en tête donc un
je le répète l'ampleur des impacts
dépend de l'ampleur des émissions
donc tout ce que je vais vous raconter à
partir de maintenant et qualitatifs semi
quantifier pour un certain nombre de
conséquences et des gens qu'on fait
tourner des modèles en disant voilà si
les émissions sont plus élevés et l
impact on est capable de le mettre dans
telle fourchette alors que si les
émissions sont plus faibles tels impacts
on mettrait plutôt dentelle fourchette
et mais ça va dépendre et surtout le
point essentiel c'est la dernière phrase
c'est à dire que ce que je vous montre à
partir de maintenant c'est illustratif
sait des choses sur lesquelles on a déjà
des indications il ya plein d'éléments
sur lesquels on va entre guillemets à
prendre en marchant c'est à dire qu on
se rendra compte une fois que c'est trop
tard qu'il ya tel truc tel coup qu'on
n'avait pas vu venir qui est en train de
se mettre en route un et ça il va y en
avoir de plus en plus donc il va falloir
vivre avec
il va y en avoir de plus en plus parce
que le système est beaucoup trop
complexe trop chaotique et trop
fortement non linéaire pour que l'on
soit capable d'identifier risque par
risc géographie par géographie et date
par date ce qui pourrait se passer ça ça
restera à jamais impossible
alors une blague que je fais souvent
c'est vous voyez il ya une expérience
qu'on a fait trois milliards de fois où
4 milliard de fois où 5 milliard de fois
chez les hommes s'appellent se marier et
pour autant un couple qui se marie
aujourd'hui vous êtes pas fichu de
savoir où il en sera dans 30 ans alors
imaginez bien qu'une expérience qu'on
fait pour la première fois et qui est
aussi complexe que celle là il est
totalement illusoire de prétendre dire à
l'avancé la totalité des conséquences
que ça aura dans quelques dizaines
d'années
donc on peut avoir une idée exactement
comme le couple je sais que dans trente
ans je sais pas si mes conjoints sont
toujours mariés ou pas mais ils ont
toujours deux bras et deux jambes sauf
si on leur a coupé ans parce qu'ils ont
un accident mais ils en auront pas 4
voilà par exemple ils feront pas 3
mètres de haut voilà donc un certain
nombre de trucs qu'on est toujours
capable de dire et puis y'a des trucs
qu'on n'est absolument pas capable de
dire j'ai pas s'ils auront 2 3 0 5
enfants et s'ils sont toujours ensemble
et si ils habiteront ici ou là encore
donc pour le climat c'est exactement
pareil
aurillac demain c'est pire puisque
encore une fois c'est une expérience
qu'on fait pour la première fois et des
expériences qu'on fait pour la première
fois c'est très très rare que ça donne
exactement des résultats qu'on est
capable de prédire à l'avancé partout et
tout le temps
une fois que j'ai 10 ans il ya un
certain nombre quand même deux
constantes dans cette affaire la
première c'est que le réchauffement aura
une structure spatiale qui est déjà à
peu près connu la prote à la première
c'est que ce que vous voyez c'est que la
température là en l'occurrence vous
l'avez en juin juillet et août
et ici en décembre janvier février ce
que vous voyez c'est que quelle que soit
la saison
l'élévation de température est plus
marquée sur les terres émergées qu'elle
ne l'est sur les océans parce que les
océans en plus d'inertie thermique
la deuxième chose que vous voyez c'est
que l'élévation de température est
proportionnellement plus marqué l'hiver
dans les hautes latitudes nord que l'été
dans les hautes latitudes d'ordi
autrement l'élévation de température ira
plus vite l'hiver que l'été c'est ce que
je vous avais déjà dit la dernière fois
ce que vous voyez également c'est que
dans tous les cas de figure il ya un
endroit et j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure
je vous expliquerai pourquoi ou
l'élévation de température est moins
marquée qu'ailleurs dans l'hémisphère
nord c'est au sud immédiat du grand
une land vous remarqué que ces présents
que ce soit l'été ou l'hiver donc la
première des conséquences que vous voyez
ici c'est que s'il ya un endroit où ça
va particulièrement chauffer c'est en
région arctique et pour ceux d'entre
vous qui suivent un peu l'actualité
vous avez peut-être déjà remarqué que
c'est en région arctique qu' il y a de
temps en temps des températures
totalement hallucinante le monde n'est
pas trop fort en hiver je crois que
c'était le 1er janvier 2018 si ma
mémoire est bonne que la température au
pôle nord était positive
je dis bien positive au dessus de zéro
la deuxième chose c'est que comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure
l'élévation de température va dépendre
du scénario démission alors ici vous
avez plus vous l'avez vous voyez
apparaître le sigle la rcp
donc je le redis représentatif compte
sur très jeunes parfois donc le 2.6
c'est un scénario dans lequel le forçage
radiatif en 2100 et de 2,6 watts par
mètre carré ce qui est à peu près celui
qu'on a aujourd'hui
en gros le 4.5 secondes à 4.5 et 6 c'est
qu'on a six watts
je vous ai enlevé ici à dessein le plus
élevé des quatre
scénario rcp utilisé aujourd'hui qui
s'appelle de 8.5 alors je voulais
enlever c'est une manipulation que
j'assume je vous ai enlevé parce que ce
scénario à rcp très élevé correspond à
des émissions très élevé c'est à dire
une situation qui pour moi est
totalement virtuelle dans laquelle
l'humanité se porterait de mieux en
mieux il y aurait de plus en plus
d'hommes avec une économie qui va de
plus en plus importante
alors même que le changement climatique
est au maximum des conséquences
possibles et donc il ya la moitié de la
planète qui meurent de faim donc c'est
un peu compliqué pour moi de raboter les
deux donc j'ai considéré que celui là je
vous en parlerai peu de temps en temps
vous le verrez quand même mais je vous
en parlerai peu parce qu'il a une
incohérence interne qui n'est pas lié
aux physiciens
j'insiste qui est lié au fait que les
scénarios sont faits par des économistes
qui n'ont pas les limites physiques par
construction c'est ce que je vous ai
expliqué au premier cours en tête
à partir du moment où l'économie dépend
pas de facteurs limitants qui viennent
de la physique
il n'y a pas de raison qu on s'empêche
d'avoir une économie qui est extrêmement
importante avec une physique très limité
pose aucun problème chez eux
moi ça me pose un problème oui
cette action de riposte
non non pas du tout c'est uniquement la
dynamique interne du modèle c'est le
fait que vous avez entre les modèles
encore une fois des hypothèses je vais
vous donner un exemple qui est très
connu la paramétrisation des nuages vous
à vous et je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
que le modèle standard il avait une
maille qui faisait 50 à 100 km de côté
pour tous ceux d'entre vous qui ont rêvé
c'est un jour il était couché dans
l'herbe en observant les nuages vous
aurez remarqué que les nuages ne font
pas cent kilomètres de côtes et comme
pour beaucoup de nuages qui vont d'ici
jusqu'à chartres et que vous pouvez voir
d'un seul tenant et impatients ou alors
ça s'appelle une couverture de stratus
et c'est déprimant et c'est l'hiver et
donc le nuage est un phénomène
soulabaille d'accord donc pour tenir
compte de la couverture nuageuse dans
les modèles vous êtes obligé de
paramétrer cette couverture dit
autrement ce que votre modèle va vous
simulez c'est la circulation de la
vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère et en
fonction de la vapeur d'eau que vous
avez dans la maille
enfin dans le dans votre boîte à
chaussures là et bien vous allez
paramétrer mais ça c'est pas un truc
dynamique c'est un truc paramétrer la
quantité de nuages que vous avez dans
cette maille d'accord et bien en
fonction des techniques qui sont
utilisés par les différents
modélisateurs pour faire cette
paramétrisation la quantité de nuages
que vous avez pour une même
concentration en vapeur d'eau et le fait
que ces nuages soit des nuages de basse
altitude où des nuages de haute altitude
qui n'ont pas le même impact sur le
climat
eh bien ça ça va varier d'un modèle à
l'autre or ne serait-ce que cette
paramétrisation là explique l'essentiel
de la dispersion des résultats entre
modèles encore le gros de la dispersion
des résultats entre modèle c'est la
façon dont les modèles approche la
représentation des nuages
un exemple qui en fait l'exemple le plus
emblématique
ça n'a absolument rien à voir avec la
rétroaction
du climat sur l'économie puisque je vous
ai dit celle-là n'est pas prise en
compte par construction dans aucune
simulation
donc ce que je disais c'est qu'en
fonction du scénario de la fin en
fonction de l'évolution de l'intensité
cassions de l'effet de serre on va dire
vous avez des réchauffements qui sont
plus ou moins marqués mais vous
retrouver à chaque fois ces constantes
c'est à dire que ça se réchauffe
proportionnellement plus sur les
continents sur les océans plus sur
l'hémisphère nord que sur l'hémisphère
sud et que vous avez toujours cette
singularité là au sud du groenland
oui c'est l'augmentation du forçage
radiatif c représente c'est
l'augmentation de la concentration de
gaz à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
donc du forçage radiatif alors c'est le
nom du scénario et la valeur que vous
avez derrière acceptez vous donne le
forçage radiatif en 2100 alors cela
étant pour une même valeur de rcp en
2100 vous pouvez avoir plusieurs
trajectoires
c'est donc là c'est une trajectoire
j'aurais pu vous les montrer mais c'est
une trajectoire
je préfère rester sur mon histoire de
scénarios d'émissions parce que en gros
ça se recoupent à peu près et le
scénario démission est un truc qu'on
visualise beaucoup plus facilement c'est
la quantité condé mais quoi
la variabilité c'est à dire des modèles
alors ça je n'ai pas variable le 2.6
c'est une trajectoire définie de forçage
par contre la dispersion par contre le
fait d'avoir vingt modèles vous donne
une dispersion des résultats parce que
vous avez un résultat par modèle mais
pour un même scénario rcp après les
mêmes modèles vous pouvez les utiliser
avec un rcp 2 6 1 cp 4,5 et c est à ce
moment évidemment ils vous donnent pas
les résultats
non non non il est par rapport à
l'époque préindustrielle
c'est à dire ces 2,6 dû à l'homme alors
est effectivement la référence et pré
industrielle due à l'homme c'est zéro
oui
alors là si quelqu'un est capable de me
faire une prévision fiable de où seront
les migrants dans ce genre d'évolution
je lui paye des cerises je prends pas de
risques ça commençait de la saison mais
ça ça fait typiquement partie des
conséquences de bout de chaîne qui sont
des trucs imprévisible ce que vous
pouvez arriver à prévoir c'est des
facteurs de pression qui vont
occasionner ce genre de choses mais
après moi je ne sais pas vous dire si
les gens vont d'abord migrer ou d'abord
mourir à cause d'une épidémie
donc s'il ya des épidémies n'iront pas
plus au nord donc je ne sais pas là la
réponse à cette question je viendrai
tout à fait en fin d'exposé sur les
conséquences parce que c'est le truc qui
vient en premier à l'esprit du
journaliste mais c'est le truc qui vient
en dernier à l'esprit du scientifique
quant à lui vient à l'esprit parce que
justement c'est très difficile d'être
prédictive sur ce genre de trucs il faut
bien voir que plus on s'éloigne de la
physique et plus on rentre dans des
choses qui nous touchent nous parce que
nous encore une fois on vit pas dans un
monde de température on vit dans un
monde d'hommes de fait qu'il y ait des
choses à manger ou pas des animaux ou
pas effectivement que les voisins
déboule chez nous ou pas c'est dans ce
monde là convient le physicien lui il
vit dans un monde de paramètres
physiques donc il a envie de rester dans
son monde et de ne pas trop s'aventurer
dans des choses qui sont voilà qu'à
chaque fois qu'on s'aventure dans une
dent des conséquences qui sont plus
proches de nos j'ai envie de dire on
rajoute une couche de complexité au
raisonnement donc une couse incertitude
donc ça veut pas dire que le risque est
pas là ça veut juste dire que c'est plus
difficile de le formaliser
j'ai rien après alors je vous ai dit
depuis 1860 on a des données
d'observation sur la variation de la
température ici en voilà
une traduction alors en l'occurrence et
depuis 1880 mais peu importe ce que vous
voyez c'est que depuis en gros les
trente glorieuses
il ya un accroissement très caractérisée
de la température et même avant alors
sur cette période là où la température
est transitoirement redescendu une des
hypothèses qui tient la corde qui vient
une des hypothèses qui tient la corde
c'est que cette phase là qui a
correspondu au début des trente
glorieuses et donc au début de
l'industrialisation accélérée de
l'humanité est également allé de pair
avec une grande grande émission de
dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère
parce qu'on utilisait beaucoup de
pétrole de plus en plus de pétrole et de
charbon qui sont des combustibles de
soufre et il n'y avait pas encore les
mesures antipollution qui a aujourd'hui
on épure est pas le dioxyde de soufre
des fumées donc on a collé plein de
sulfate dans l'atmosphère et donc on a
un peu refroidi climat à cause de ça
c'est ça l'explication la plus enfin eu
des explications qui tient la corde
parce que vous remarquez que si vous
partez d'ici et que vous faites quelque
chose qui est il ya la même tendance
avec un pic là qui se prolongent
derrière puis après vous avez une
accélération
ce que vous voyez également c'est que là
dessus la tendance elle est très claire
alors ça n'empêche pas un certain nombre
de gens même encore aujourd'hui de
prendre de la série courte qui les
arrange en disant vouloir garder la
température baisse ça s'est arrêté de
monter puisque la température baisse
d'accord évidemment il faut regarder la
série longue
donc il faut appliquer le bon filtre il
faut pas regarder les séries courtes
vous allez me dire des
climato-sceptiques y aura de moins en
moins c'est pas complètement sûr ça
dépend énormément du pays où on est et
il se trouve qu il ya un pays qui est
maintenant plus le 1er mai le deuxième
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre au
monde qui a une toute petite influence
sur le reste des pays occidentaux parce
que il détient pour le moment la monnaie
de réserve par excellence qui s'appelle
le dollar et ce pays possède à la plus
forte proportion de climato sceptiques
au monde après l'arabie saoudite et je
sais plus quel est le deuxième
donc oui c'est à peu près 20% et des
gens qui sont durement j'ai envie de
dire pas d pad et avec la même mesure en
france et 6 % maintenant pavé en 15
pendant 15 mai avec la même mesure la
france et six donc c'est en gros deux
fois plus que la france c'est très
différenciée après en fonction de la
région la région géographique voilà mais
ce cette petite animation encore une
fois est là pour rappeler que c'est très
facile de manipuler des statistiques
pour leur faire dire ce qu'elles ne
disent pas et là vous avez un exemple
particulièrement
particulièrement classique j'ai envie de
dire de ce genre de manipulation il n'y
a pas que la température globale qu'on
peut analyser avec les relevés de
température
alors ici vous avez une évolution de la
température hémisphérique et vous voyez
par exemple que les variations de
température de l'hémisphère sud sont
globalement un peu moins heurtée et un
peu moins rapide désormais que les
variations de l'hémisphère nord c'est la
conséquence de ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure
plus deux continents sur l'hémisphère
nord et une évolution plus rapide en
article ici vous avez également des
moyennes différencier entre les
continents et l'océan
voilà donc on retrouve la conclusion de
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure au
dessus des continents vous voyez là
cette baisse probablement due à
l'industrialisation croissante
là vous voyez que c'est maintenant ça
évolue plus lentement que au dessus des
continents ce qui est tout à fait normal
avec les différentes d'inertie thermique
ici vous avez la cour pour la france
donc vous voyez que la france
aujourd'hui à des anomalies de
températures par rapport à la moyenne 61
90 qui sont désormais toutes positives
et qui on a tendance qui entendent ans
augmente ce qui fait que par exemple
toute votre vie durant
vous verrez dans le journal tant qu'il y
aura des journaux à intervalles
réguliers on vient de battre le record
de température
bah oui puis on va les battre et puis
encore et puis encore et puis encore et
encore
tant qu'il y aura des gens pour mesurer
la température et des journaux pour
imprimer des trucs sur la température on
va battre périodiquement des records de
température oui pardon
on s'en fiche on importe quelle
référence vous mettez pour caractériser
une variation vous mettez le zéro
désordonné où les aidants l'occurrence
la loi n'est pas s'en tenir là les
trentenaires on a coutume alors par
contre ce qui est sûr c'est que en ce
qui concerne le climat
on a tendance à considérer que la la
série minimale pour regarder ce qui se
passe quelque part c'est trente ans
quelque chose qui ici vous avez une
variation des températures hivernales et
estivales en france là aussi depuis un
siècle
alors ce que vous voyez et ça c'est un
truc qui est intéressant à garder en
tête notamment pour le dimensionnement
du système électrique c'est que la
variation de température en ce qui
concerne l'hiver qui est la même qu'en
ce qui concerne l'été c'est à dire ça
augmente dans tous les cas de figure et
bien n'éclipse pas une variabilité
annuel qui a tendance à être plus
importante que en ce qui concerne
n'était donc ici vous avez un point qui
est extrêmement singulier vous voyez
mais sinon les anomalies de température
se ressemble quand même beaucoup d'une
année sur l'autre alors que là les
anomalies de températures d'une année
sur l'autre elles peuvent varier et
normale peuvent varier de façon beaucoup
plus importante et donc ce que vous
dites graphique en particulier c'est que
le réchauffement climatique dans son
ensemble n'empêchera empêche pas plus
exactement aujourd'hui la survenue de
temps en temps d'hiver qui peuvent est
resté plus froid que la moyenne
ça n'empêche pas ça ça veut dire c'est
évidemment moins en moins fréquent mais
ça ne m'empêche pas
vous avez maintenant oui la normale
saisonnière c'est toujours pareil c'est
la moyenne sur le 30 ans 61 90 mais
encore une fois c'est juste une affaire
de déplacement du l'origine une une des
manières de savoir si ce qui a déjà eu
lieu comme réchauffement à la surface de
la planète est bien due à un supplément
d'effet de serre c'est certes de
regarder si les modèles vous donne une
élévation de température au sol qui est
cohérente avec le supplément des effets
de serre qu'on a mis dans l'atmosphère
mais une autre manière d'avoir cette
confirmation c'est de regarder si la
structure spatiale de l'élévation de
température correspond à ce qu'on est en
droit d'attendre d'un climat qui se
réchauffe avec un supplément d'effet de
serre et je crois que je l'avais déjà
dit une fois précédentes mais sinon je
vais le redire dans un climat qui se
réchauffe par supplément d'effet de
serre une des choses qu'on doit
s'attendre à trouver
c'est une élévation de température plus
marquée sur les continents est
particulièrement marquée en zone
arctique est ici vous avez une
reconstruction des températures
variations de température sur le xxème
siècle est ce que vous voyez c'est que
c'est ça qu'on observe aujourd'hui dans
l'élévation de température qui est déjà
observez vous voyez que c'est
particulièrement marquée en zone
arctique et que c'est plus
particulièrement marquée sur les
continents que sur les océans où ça
s'est réchauffée et vous voyez également
quelque chose
encore une fois je reviendrai plus tard
qu'on a bien cette singularité ici au
sud du groenland
une des conséquences du réchauffement
des températures c'est que bien
évidemment on va avoir une augmentation
des températures maximales à partir du
moment où les températures obéissent à
une distribution
si vous ne changez pas à la forme de la
distribution et que vous déplacer la
moyenne vous avez évidemment une
quantité enfin vous allez voir
apparaître des événements qui dépasse la
température maximale que vous aviez
avant voyez si la température maximale
était là et que vous déplacez votre
moyenne les températures maximales
atteintes seront ici maintenant temps
que vous changez pas la forme de lagos
yens et bien la quantité la densité on
va dire de probabilité pour les
événements qui dépasse la toile
les anciennes températures maximales
sont pas extrêmement importante
par contre si dans le même temps vous
augmentez la variabilité alors là vous
allez voir apparaître une augmentation
beaucoup plus importante des événements
qui vont dépasser
l'ancien maximum or il se trouve que
malheureusement on s'attend dans un
climat qui se réchauffe à ce que la
variabilité augmente aussi
c'est une des conséquences qui est
attendu ce qui veut dire que les
événements extrêmement chaud loin ou
extrêmement secs vont avoir tendance à
augmenter j'ai envie de dire plus vite
que la moyenne
il ya un autre élément de variabilité
qui peut entrer en jeu
et là je vais vous donner l'exemple de
l'europe l'europe
comme vous le savez est soumise à un
régime de vents d'ouest
il se trouve que au dessus de
l'atlantique
vous avez deux régimes enfin vous avez
cap régime pardon de positionnement
respectif de la dépression et de
l'anticyclone qui peuvent se produire
vous avez un régime celui là qu'on
appelle le n a au moins dans lequel vous
avez
alors l'anticyclone au nord et la
dépression au sud
vous avez ici un régime dans lequel
c'est l'exact inverse
c'est une structuration est ouest est
ici une régime dans lequel c'est une
structuration est-ouest inverse
ici vous avez la fréquence d'occurrence
de ces situations dans l'année d'accord
ce que vous disent année par les donc ce
que vous dites c'est graphique c'est que
avec une variabilité annuel forte quand
même en gros sur quelques décennies vous
avez à peu près 25 % de probabilité de
vous retrouver dans l'une des quatre
situations donc dit autrement si vous
regardez sur quelques décennies vous
faites abstraction de la variation
annuelle
ça ça se produit 25% du temps ça 25 125
125 et quand vous êtes dans chacune de
ses quatre situations vous voyez ici que
les températures et les précipitations
présentent des anomalies par rapport à
la moyenne qui sont pas les mêmes
donc quand vous êtes en rouge c'est que
vous avez un surplus et en bleu c'est
que vous avez un déficit en fait
attention pour les températures et les
précipitations s'interprète pas de la
même manière évidemment
et vous voyez que le surplus et le
déficit sont pas du tout situé au même
endroit en fonction de la situation que
vous avez sur l'atlantique donc ici avec
en inversant le north atlantic
oscillation
eh bien vous voyez que les surplus et
les déficits sont en gros inversé sur la
partie nord de l'europe
là c'est pareil en inversant ces deux
situations et bien vous voyez que sur la
partie nord de l'europe vous avez des
situations extrêmement contrastées
en ce qui concerne les précipitations
une des questions à laquelle les
modélisateurs de sap à répondre
aujourd'hui
c est ce que la fréquence d'occurrence
de chacune de ces quatre situation
change dans un climat qui se réchauffe
si la réponse est oui ça veut dire que
vous avez un phénomène d'amplification
sur l'europe par rapport à l'évolution
globale soit dans un sens ce soit dans
l'autre si la situation d'amplification
va dans le sens de moins de
précipitation et plus de température
mais beaucoup plus mal que si ça va dans
l'autre sens et j'insiste c'est beaucoup
plus mal encore parce que vous avez un
impact direct sur ce qui se mange et un
impact direct sur ce qui pousse et c'est
très difficile aujourd'hui de savoir
quoi que ce soit là dessus avec la
modélisation alors applications ici vous
avez la distribution des températures en
suisse alors me demandez pas pourquoi la
suisse mais c'est probablement parce que
c'est une équipe de chercheurs suisses
qui a fait ça dans la situation pré
industrielle dans la moyenne
il importe quoi la moyenne de la fin du
xxème siècle est ici le climat futur à
la fin du 21e siècle
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que non
seulement la distribution des
températures a changé de moyenne mais
vous voyez également que la variabilité
a considérablement augmenté et donc les
températures extrêmement élevées vont
pas être un peu plus fréquentes elles
vont être considérablement plus
fréquentes
alors vous êtes un peu jeune pour vous
souvenir de la canicule de 2003
peut-être parce que c'était quand il ya
16 ans de 16 ans vous étiez pas où je
sais pas qui s'en souvient de la
canicule de 2003 oui quand même
et bien la canicule de 2003 ce que je
vais vous dire c'est que dans un climat
qui se réchauffe de quelques degrés de
quelques degrés donc ce qu'on est parti
pour faire
eh bien ça devient il était normal alors
l'été normal c'est l'été normale au sens
statistique
c'est à dire que c'est l'été qui se
retrouvent qui départage 50% des étaient
les plus frais de 50% des étés les plus
chauds
ça veut donc dire que à la fin du siècle
avec un réchauffement de quelques degrés
l'été 2003 50% des étés sont plus chaud
que celui là alors dans les conséquences
que vous pouvez facilement imaginer pour
les radios forêt on peut dire adieu à
une partie des récoltes etc
c'est assez facile de comprendre que
tout ça
disparue voilà donc c'est pour faire
comprendre qu'une variation de quelques
degrés de la moyenne planétaire san ça
n'est pas du tout représentatif de la
limite supérieure du supplément de
température qu'on peut prendre dans les
épisodes les plus chauds c'est pas du
tout représentatif de sang dans les
autres marques du réchauffement
climatique au niveau du sol qui sont
attendus je vous en avais parlé la
dernière fois en vous parlant du
processus physiques à l'oeuvre c'est à
dire du fait que en interceptant la
température plus près du sol on allait
en avoir moins qu'ils seraient
interceptés dans la haute atmosphère
eh bien on doit s'attendre à avoir un
refroidissement de la stratosphère
ce que vous voyez sur cette courbe c'est
que depuis qu'on sait mesurer la
température dans la stratosphère c'est à
dire depuis le début des ballons sondes
eh bien on sait mesurer donc la
température dans la stratosphère
est ce qu'on constate c'est qu'elles
baissent et elles baissent d'une façon
qui est logique avec le supplément
d'effet de serre la deuxième conséquence
qui va ya voir avec le réchauffement
climatique où exactement avec le
changement climatique
c'est une variation des précipitations
alors ce que je vous ai dit au moment où
je vous ai simuler le fonctionnement
global du système la dernière fois avec
la petite animation que je vous ai
projeté c'est que dans un climat plus
chaud vous avez globalement plus
d'évaporation et donc plus des
précipitations
par contre cette évaporation pendant ces
précipitations parlons n'ont pas de
raison de se répartir de façon homogène
à la surface de la planète ni
spatialement ni temporellement est donc
la grande question c'est qu'est ce qui
se passe pour l'évolution de ces
précipitations
il ya une difficulté de modélisation et
qui est lié à ce que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure sur les nuages qui est que comme
les précipitations sont associés à la
couverture nuageuse et bien si on a du
mal à paramétrer la couverture nuageuse
on a une incertitude qui est plus forte
que sur l'élévation de température sur
la variation des précipitations
il n'empêche qu'on a quand même quelques
conclusions assez robuste lorsque vous
voyez c'est que globalement les
précipitations vont avoir à temps on va
avoir tendance à augmenter fortement
dans les hautes latitudes nord alors ça
nous intéresse qu à moitié parce qu'il
n'a pas beaucoup de monde qui vit là bas
par contre ce que vous voyez c'est qu'il
ya des régions où les précipitations
vont avoir tendance à baisser
alors si vous regardez cette carte un
peu de façon macroscopique ce que vous
constatez c'est que les précipitations
augmente aux hautes latitudes ainsi que
globalement dans la bande équatoriale
je dis bien la bande équatoriale par
contre elles vont avoir tendance à
baisser
ça va avoir tendance à baisser fortement
dans les bandes tropicale que vous voyez
ici et là est la région du monde où les
précipitations vont le plus baissé pas
de chance c'est chez nous vous voyez que
là où les précipitations vont le plus
diminué dans l'ensemble des régions du
monde c'est pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen et le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen et notamment le fait d'un
certain nombre de pays ici qui sont pas
du tout autosuffisant sur le plan
alimentaire qui aujourd'hui ont besoin
d'importer de la nourriture pour une
population rapidement croissante et en
fait j'ai pas le temps aujourd'hui mais
j'ai fait une conférence à physique
chimie paris
il ya quatre ans dont le titre était de
déchets la cap 21 dans laquelle je
m'explique en quoi ce qu'on a appelé le
printemps arabe à un déterminant énergie
climat extrêmement important et en fait
il s'est agi là bas des bottes de la
faim dans des pays importateurs qui
n'étaient pas capables de compenser par
des impôts qui était pas capable de
subventionner leurs importations pour
leurs populations et donc il s'est passé
exactement la même chose qu'en 1789
c'est à dire et bottes et la syrie à un
processus déclencheur qui n'est pas très
très éloignées ce genre de choses va se
répéter d'accord on est parti pour que
ce genre de processus se répète tout
simplement parce que les précipitations
vont s'affronter continuer à s'affaiblir
dans le pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
et donc ça va rendre encore plus
difficile ces pays
enfin encore plus difficile pardon
l'autosuffisance alimentaire de ces pays
et par ailleurs je prends à qui son
attrait et par ailleurs la sécheresse va
malheureusement avoir tendance à
remonter vers le sud de l'europe
et vous savez peut-être que rien
qu'aujourd'hui déjà l'espagne à une
agriculture qui est pour partie
alimentée par le pompage de nappes qui
ne se renouvelle pas donc c'est un
problème qui va tout à fait concerner
les européens sur leur propre sol aussi
dans pas si longtemps que ça oui
ça c'est alors quand le modèle coop et
vieques présente ce genre de truc c'est
des tendances intermodal sur une
vingtaine de modèles à ça alors c'est
une conclusion malheureusement très
robuste c'est à dire que tous les
modèles convergent sur le fait que le
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen va
s'assécher
vous avez des endroits là où vous avez
du blanc c'est que vous n'avez pas de
convergence entre modèle typiquement un
là vous avez c'est malheureusement très
très convergent alors après vous n'avez
pas que les précipitations qui compte
vous avez également la variation de
l'évaporation parce que la teneur en eau
du sol qui vous conditionne le fait que
les plantes puissent pousser ou pas est
le résultat de ce qui tombe
- le résultat de ce qui s'évapore ou de
ski file rapidement par exemple dans les
zones de mousson où la pluie est
également quelque chose qui est
absolument crucial pour que les gens
puissent survivre
et bien vous pouvez avoir des
précipitations qui s'intensifie mais qui
arrive après une période sèche qui a été
plus sèche donc un sol qui est plus
imperméable et à ce moment l'eau
ruisselle sur le sol fait des
inondations soit dit en passant mais
n'est pas conservé par le sol et donc
elle n'est pas bonne entre guillemets
pour la végétation
l'idéal pour la végétation pour ceux
d'entre vous qui sont allés en irlande
ou en bretagne c'est le petit crachin
démoralisant toute l'année ça c'est
absolument parfait c'est qu'il fasse
beau trop fort par jour comme disent les
irlandais donc ça c'est l'idéal
mais quand vous avez des épisodes qui
sont très concentrés malheureusement
c'est pas très bons non plus alors ce
que vous voyez ici donc c'est
l'évaporation et vous voyez alors faites
attention parce que la graduation c'est
que plus ces bleus plus ça augmente et
vous voyez que dans un certain nombre de
régions du monde et en particulier sur
l'essentiel des terres émergées
l'évaporation se baladent quelque part
entre la même chose qu'aujourd'hui à
plus intense qu'aujourd'hui donc dans
tous les cas de figure même s'il pleut
plus vous allez avoir une évaporation en
particulier terrestre qui va avoir
tendance à s'intensifier et donc ici
vous avez quelque chose qui est un
composite de ce que je viens d'évoquer
donc précipitations évaporation et qui
ça et qui est l'évolution de l'humidité
des sols
donc ça en fait ça vous pilote
directement le rendement agricole en vo
et le fait que les écosystèmes se porte
bien ou pas bien
ce que vous voyez ici c'est qu'on va
retrouver donc des choses dont je vous
ai déjà parlé donc le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen a tendance à s'assécher
voilà là où vous avez des pointillés
c'est là où les conclusions sont très
robustes
c'est ça la manière de comprendre cette
jeu philippe commentait je prends la
question après c'est que c'est la façon
de prendre ce graphique vous voyez
également cette partie de l'australie
dans le quart sud ouest qui est en train
de s'assécher un petit peu le sud est
aussi en or pour ceux d'entre vous qui
suivent c'est là que vous avez des
agriculteurs de temps en temps qui sont
pas très heureux de ce qui arrive
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
des problèmes d'eau qui en afrique du
sud
et vous voyez que c'est cohérent avec ce
que vous voyez là alors ça c'est l'après
mauvaise nouvelle si vous avez le bassin
amazonien qui s'assèchent
ça c'est quelque chose qui va pas être
du tout pour la forêt et là vous avez le
plus grand stock de carbone sur pied de
la planète
vous voyez également ici la sécheresse
qui s'intensifie sur le sud des états
unis et sur le mexique alors le mexique
c'est comme l'afrique du nord population
en croissance
intensification des sécheresses et donc
de la de la disponibilité en eau c'est
pareil la question de savoir comment
tout ça se termine est un gros point
d'interrogation
je vous le disais tout à l'heure il peut
pleuvoir
ah oui pardon y avait une question au
fond oui
alors qu'en dit non parce que la vapeur
d'eau condense en fait ce que vous avez
dans l'atmosphère c'est une pression de
vapeur saturante et si vous évaporé plus
il pleut plus ça n'augmente pas la
pression de vapeur saturante ça circule
plus vite
simplement ce qui conditionne la
pression de vapeur saturante c'est la
température de l'atmosphère donc plus la
température est élevée et plus sa
capacité en encore de vapeur d'eau ou en
concentration de vapeur d'eau dans
l'atmosphère plus exactement quelle est
humide en eau plus sa capacité à être
humide est élevé oui oui sauf qu'ils ne
la prennent pas en compte oui ça
tamponne ray les émissions phase aller
salle et ça les amorties rsa et ferait
baisser mais il le prétend c'est très
compliqué parce que encore une fois vous
commencé à toucher un peu du doigt la
complexité du truc parti passer parce
que là on est dans les paramètres
physiques encore après par exemple quand
on va commencer à faire des simulations
agronomique
avec l'évolution de ces paramètres
physiques on rajoute un étage de
complexité donc faut aller demander à
vos copains de la grolle enfin qui sont
là encore pour le moment mais qui vont
bientôt être à saclay comme tout le
monde il faut allez leur demander
rigolez pas c'est toujours quand je
pleure
il faut allez leur demander comment ça
marche quand on rajoute la biologie de
la plante par-dessus l'évolution de ces
paramètres physiques et la réponse c'est
que c'est compliqué vous allez voir un
peu plus tard lorsque vous mangez c'est
pas des paramètres physiques cd plantes
et les animaux qui rangeait les plantes
ce que vous donne cette graphique c'est
l'évolution des phénomènes pluvieux
intenses qui sont telles que ça a été
constaté
cette fois ci dans le passé est ce que
vous voyez c'est que il ya déjà une
tendance à l'augmentation dont klaus et
vert et bleu dans un certain nombre
d'endroits donc le surplus de
précipitation peut arriver sous forme
malheureusement d'une augmentation des
précipitations sur des laps de temps
extrêmement court et ça s'est perdu pour
tout le monde parce que c'est de l'eau
que les soldes ne garde pas et en plus
ça fait des dégâts
ce que vous voyez ici là pour le coup
c'est aussi l'évolution passée des de la
deûle indice de sécheresse des sols et
vous voyez qu'il ya un certain nombre de
régions dans le monde où on retrouve des
tendances qui sont prévus pour plus tard
alors
là c'est comme si au billet du sahara ce
n'est pas très significatif mais vous
voyez que sur l'afrique du sud on
retrouve ça sur le pourtour
méditerranéen on retrouve ça sur le
sud-est et le sud-ouest de l'australie
on retrouve ça sur cette partie du
brésil on retrouve ça et sur le sud des
états unis on retrouve ça donc il ya
déjà quelques régions dans le monde où
il semblerait que l'on soit déjà en
train de d'avoir des sols qui sont en
train de s'assécher comme on s'attend à
la voir dans le cadre d'un climat qui se
réchauffe en france vous avez un
phénomène de précipitations intenses qui
s'appelle les épisodes cévenols
est ce que vous connaissez non les
épisodes cévenols cd épisode qui arrive
à la fin de l'été à un moment où la
méditerranée est encore chaude et où les
la température sur la terre a commencé à
se refroidir
et il arrive quand vous avez de l'air
humide venu du sud passé au dessus de la
méditerranée donc chargés en eau qui
remonte en altitude
donc avec condensation de la vapeur
d'eau en rencontrant les cévennes donc
on rentre rencontrant les contreforts du
massif central
à ce moment il pleut des trombes le
ministre de l'environnement chose ses
bottes et va visiter la ville qui a été
inondée voilà c'est ça un épisode
cévenol
la fin est maintenant devenue
obligatoire une question qui se pose
évidemment c'est à partir du moment où
vous avez une température de surface qui
se réchauffe
vous allez donc avoir une méditerranée
qui va rester chaude plus longtemps
question est ce que ça ne va pas
augmenter ce genre d'épisode alors la
réponse est que pour le moment c'est
compliqué de le dire s'est pas
complètement sûr que ce soit le cas et
vous avez ici une série longue qui est
fait par météo france sur la quantité
d'épisodes cévenols en france avec deux
seuils de cumul vous voyez ici sans et
pardon 190 et 150 et vous voyez que vous
c'est pas clair que pour le moment il ya
quelque chose qui soit franchement à la
hausse
par contre ce qui est sûr et donc ça
c'est un deuxième truc qu'il faut avoir
en tête en ce qui concerne les
conséquences c'est que la quantité de
biens a inondé augmente parce que la
france est toujours en processus
d'urbanisation tiers la taille des
villes continué d'augmenter en continu
de construire chaque année quelques
centaines de milliers de logements
donc ces logements on les met quelque
part on les met pas en étage
supplémentaire sur ce qui existe déjà
on occupe plus d'espacé au sol et il se
trouve que dans le sud comme ailleurs la
quasi totalité des villes ont été
construites avec un cours d'eau qui les
traversent
parce que historiquement c'était l'accès
à l'eau potable ou l'accès à l'eau qu'on
utilisait pour autre chose notamment
pour laver le linge
vous connaissez vous les machines à
laver moi aussi ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas
bref il fallait de l'eau pour abreuver
les bêtes enfin bon bref donc on avait
besoin d'eau et donc toutes les villes
de france ont été construites sur un
cours d'eau les plus grosses sur des
fleuves qui servait de voies de
communication
à partir du moment où le cours d'eau
grossit rapidement on passe car
d'épisodes cévenols et ben si vous avez
des trucs trop près du cours d'eau boum
c'est inondées quand vous avez une
pression foncière avec de nouveaux
habitants qui veulent faire construire
et que vous avez déjà construit tous les
endroits qu'ils allaient bien ou est-ce
que vous donner l'autorisation de
construire dans des endroits qui vont
moins bien et notamment trop près du
cours d'eau donc vous avez des
constructions additionnel en quantité
croissante qui se met là où il faut pas
parce que les élus sont pas capables de
résister à la pression des électeurs et
à ce moment quand y'a une inondation il
ya plus de trucs qui casse le truc le
plus drôle que j'ai vu c'est une caserne
de pompiers ou les pompiers normalement
sont mobilisés contre les inondations
qui étaient inondées
une fois donc là on était dans les
paramètres physiques donc à ce stade je
résume la température va augmenter pas
partout de la même manière elle va
augmenter plus vite en réchauffant l'os
et enfin il va y avoir plus d'énergie
qu'ils réchauffent l'océan que d'énergie
qui réchauffe l'atmosphère et ça va
impacter le régime des pluies
maintenant on va s'intéresser à une
conséquence une première conséquence sur
le vivant parce qu'encore une fois c'est
ça qui nous intéresse vraiment et ici
vous avez une carte qui vous représente
le types d'écosystèmes que vous avez
aujourd'hui à la surface de la planète
si on les coupe pas pour faire autre
chose et vous avez surtout ici une un
diagramme qui vous donne le genre
d'écosystèmes que vous allez trouver en
fonction des précipitations et de la
température
est ce que vous constatez c'est que et
c'est pour ça que c'est important
d'avoir une bonne visibilité sur les
précipitations vous changer beaucoup
plus vite de types d'écosystèmes si vous
modifiez les précipitations que si vous
modifiez la température c'est pour ça
qu'en fait le point essentiel dans le
changement climatique en cours
c'est pas tant les variations de
température que les variations de
précipitations qui vont avec
évidemment mais c'est surtout ça qui va
être essentiel la végétation va changer
et malheureusement elle va pas changer
en général dans le bon sens au sens de
on va avoir beaucoup plus de disparition
que de création parce que le temps qu'il
faut pour créer quelque chose c'est
beaucoup plus long que le temps qu'il
faut pour disparaître les simulations
que je vais vous montrer maintenant sont
nécessairement des simulations partiel
parce que les phénomènes qui sont les
plus dommageables pour les hommes et les
plantes c'est pas tant les modifications
plus exactement ça peut être les
modification de paramètres physiques par
exemple s'il ya plus d'eau c'est clair
que les plantes crève mais vous pouvez
également avoir une variation de la
compétition entre espèces qui fait
d'énormes dégâts et dans la compétition
entre espèces vous avez typiquement ce
qu'on appelle les ravageurs donc les
insectes les microbes les virus les
champignons alors quand je parle des
champignons c'est pas les champs puis
c'est pas les beaux l'air
je parle de l'oïdium du mildiou et enfin
un truc sympathique de ce type là est
bien quand vous avez bien ces processus
là ils sont extrêmement difficilement
mobilisables
dit autrement quelle est la fraction des
chaînes a qui vont mourir parce qu'ils
vont être victimes d attaques d'oïdium à
un moment où il faudrait pas dans un
climat qui se réchauffe ya pas un modèle
aujourd'hui qui sait vous dire ce genre
de truc de façon fiable donc ici c'est
les précautions qu'il faut avoir sur ce
que je vais vous montrer c'est que
quelque part c'est déborde inférieur et
s'est pas démentie nférieure c'est
plutôt c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
comprendre
ici vous avez la répartition dû être en
france aujourd'hui donc plus plus la
densité est élevé et plus on va vers le
rouge et plus sinon est faible donc en
gros vous avez le droit d'avoir des
êtres partout en france mais globalement
vous en avez plus facilement ici que
l'or est plus facilement dans les
pyrénées que la et à droite vous avez la
répartition des êtres que vous pourriez
avoir en 2100 dans un climat qui est
modifiée par le plus faible des
scénarios d'émission qu'on a vu jusqu'à
maintenant donc ce que vous voyez c'est
qu'il ya tout un tas de régions france
où il n'est plus possible d'avoir des
êtres essentiellement parce qu'il fait
trop sec même répartition pour le sapin
sapin est bien les endroits où il fait
un peu frais divers
eh bien vous voyez que frais l'hiver
c'est plus difficile dans un climat qui
se modifie et donc vous avez les
endroits où vous pouvez avoir des
certains qui se rétrécissent voilà une
autre conséquence du réchauffement
climatique
ici vous avez l'un flammes et
l'inflammabilité pardon des forêts
aujourd'hui avec trois index là et là ça
brûle très facilement là et là ça brûle
encore raisonnablement facilement
ailleurs pour le moment ça brûle pas
donc ça c'est aujourd'hui ça c'est en
eh bien vous voyez qu'en 2040
l'inflammabilité de la forêt de
fontainebleau qui est là est celle de
l'aquitaine aujourd'hui donc il y aura
des incendies dans la forêt de
fontainebleau
malheureusement j'ai beaucoup la forêt
de fontainebleau ce que vous voyez c'est
que l'aquitaine brûlera aussi facilement
que le pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
etc
et c'est je vous dis pas ça en étant
content si je vous dis ça parce que
c'est malheureusement ce qui va se
passer
rappelez-vous que à 20 ans c'est un non
pas je voulais pas dit je crois en
empare dont je vais vous
parce que c'est un truc qui est
essentiel je vais revenir un tout petit
peu en arrière pour vous dire ça je vais
revenir
là alors vous ne voyez pas bien sur ce
graphique mais quand même ce que vous
voyez c'est que toutes les simulations
pour l'avenir dans les dix ans même si
on arrête les émissions et dans les 20 à
30 ans quel que soit le scénario
démission si on les augmente la
trajectoire est exactement la même
donc en gros ce qui va se passer en 2040
est devenu totalement indépendant est
totalement indépendant de ce que seront
nos émissions à partir de maintenant ce
qui va se passer après 2040 va commencer
à être différencié en fonction de nos
émissions et mais vous voyez que avant
il n'y a pas de différences en fonction
des scénarios d'émissions donc il ya une
conséquence absolument majeur c'est que
dans cette histoire c'est évidemment ça
qui est une des difficultés de la faire
quelque part en ce qui concerne
l'atténuation du changement climatique
on travaille au mieux pour ses enfants
alors on travaille au mieux pour ses
enfants
en ce qui concerne l'adaptation au
changement climatique
là on travaille clairement pour soi donc
le fait par exemple que dès à présent je
vais aller mettre dans la forêt de
fontainebleau des tous les dispositifs
imaginables qui vont l'empêcher ball et
ça c'est un truc qu'on fait pour soi
même dira pour sa propre génération
le fait de demander aux français et aux
allemands aux chinois aux indiens aux
américains et aux russes de moins et m
pour que la forêt de fontainebleau brûle
un peu moins facilement ça c'est un truc
qu'on fait pour la génération qui suit c
est clair malheureusement à cause de
l'inertie du système
alors on continue dans les conséquences
ici vous avez un graphique un nouveau
compliquée parce que tous les graphiques
du giec sont compliquées exactement
toujours très riche en informations qui
vous donne
par types d'espèces d'accord donc ici
raccorder ici par exemple vous avez les
rongeurs
ici vous avez les mammifères je pense
ici vous avez les insectes donc partir
d'espèces qui vous donne là vous avez
les arbres qui vous donne la plage de
migration possible de l'espèce en
kilomètres par décennie dit autrement
quand je vais réchauffer le climat
je vais pousser vers les pôles les zones
climatiques d'accord en termes de
température 1
là où j'avais les températures que j'ai
aujourd'hui à 45° ben je vais retrouver
dans quelques années ou quelques
décennies je vais les retrouver à 48 50
55 degrés de latitude
donc je vais pousser les zones
favorables vers les pôles et donc si je
veux que mes espèces survive il faut
qu'elles soient capables de migrer à la
vitesse à laquelle les zones se déplace
à la vitesse à laquelle vous allez
déplacer les paramètres climatiques
est ce que vous dit ce graphique c'est
que ça vous donne les plages les
vitesses auxquels ces espèces peuvent se
déplacer en kilomètres par décennie ce
que vous avez en barres noires
horizontales
c'est la moyenne on va dire par
catégorie d'espèce une forme moyenne est
ici vous avez des traits de couleurs qui
vous donne les vitesses de déplacement
associés aux différents scénarios
d'émissions donc en gros ce que vous
cela ça vous dit c'est que dans le rcp
2.6 donc le plus bas des scénarios
d'émissions sur les zones de plaine et
bien en moyenne ça va se déplacer à
cette vitesse là
et c'est donc là vous avez les allées
les global
pour ses scénarios sur en plein ce que
vous voyez c'est que là où c'est plat ça
va se déplacer plus vite que en moyenne
tout simplement parce que là où vous
avez du relief vous n'êtes pas obligé de
monter en latitude vous pouvez monter en
altitude les espèces que vous avez dans
les alpes resteront dans les alpes sauf
qu'elles seront plus autant d'altitude
par contre quand vous êtes en plein ça
va être poussé vers les pôles ce que
vous voyez c'est que par exemple quand
on est en rc p60 et bien vous avez une
vitesse de déplacement vers les pôles
qui excède de beaucoup la vitesse
moyenne de déplacement vers les pôles
possible pour les arbres parce que la
chaîne met 40 ou 50 ans être
sexuellement mature donc il fait pas des
sauts de puce comme ça tous les ans pour
se déplacer vers les pôles d'accord il
faut que ça attendre le franchissement
d'une génération avant que ça aille
s'installer ailleurs
donc ce que vous dit ce graphique en
gros c'est que en rcp 6 0 ou même en
rire c'est p45 en gros vous allez perdre
l'essentiel des forêts voilà ce que ça
vous dit en ce qui concerne les espèces
herbacées c'est pareil vous allez en
perdre une partie
par contre les une partie des mammifères
sauf que si vous avez plus de quoi
manger pour les mammifères ce truc là
devient partiellement virtuel et c'est
donc ce que vous voyez en gros c'est que
pour la base des écosystèmes c'est à
dire les plantes
vous avez une vitesse de migration
possible de ces écosystèmes vers les
pôles qui est très inférieur pour
l'essentiel des espèces à la vitesse de
déplacement des paramètres climatiques
on va observer c'est ça que vous dit ce
diagramme et donc quand on dit que ça va
être une perte d'écosystèmes
c'est exactement à ça que c'est dû
là vous avez un graphique qui vous parle
cette fois ci non pas des écosystèmes
sauvage mais des écosystèmes diriger
c'est à dire de l'agriculture donc
l'agriculture et par l'éco système mono
spécifique dirigée
c'est ça c'est à dire que vous avez une
seule espèce de l'eau spécifique celle
qui pousse qui nous intéresse les autres
on s'en fout alors maintenant c'est vrai
un peu moins parce que on essaye de
commencer à faire des choses différentes
est ce que vous disent ce que vous
disent ce graphique c'est que ils vous
donnent la tendance actuelle je dis bien
la tendance actuelle sur la variation
par décennie des rendements agricoles
est ce que vous voyez c'est que dès à
présent vous avez deux espèces qui sont
le blé et le maïs sur lesquels on a déjà
une tendance à la baisse sur les
rendements agricoles
vous avez ici les quatre principales
céréales cultivées dans le monde 1
le blé le soja le riz et le maïs dont la
production annuelle est de l'ordre de 2
milliards de tonnes un peu plus de 2
milliards de tonnes et vous voyez donc
pour le moment en tout cas il y en a pas
une qui en profite ici ça vous donne le
résultat prospectifs donc ce que vous
donne le résultat prospectifs quand vous
faites des simulations c'est qu'on
s'attend avec une barre d'erreurs
importantes
évidemment à ce que les rendements
agricoles continue à décroître à
l'avenir sous l'effet du réchauffement
climatique
et vous voyez que là où ça va où ça
pourrait baisser plus vite c'est dans
les régions tempérées
si on n'a pas de mesures d'adaptation
mais sauf que dans les mesures
d'adaptation vous avez par exemple
irrigation et l'irrigation c'est pas
nécessairement quelque chose qui est
facile à mettre en avant parce que s'ils
s'arrêtent de pleuvoir de façon
significative enfin s'il pleut moins
l'irrigation et pas nécessairement
beaucoup plus simple alors ça c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument majeur
sur une planète dont la population par
ailleurs a tendance à augmenter pour le
moment parce que je vous rappelle ce
vieux dicton encore une fois qui est à
l'origine de 1789 c'est ventre affamé
n'a point d'oreille bondy autrement
quand les gens ont pas mangées ils
deviennent fous et c'est normal et c'est
normal donc le fait que les rendements
agricoles baissent alors pour répondre à
la question de tout à l'heure à quel
moment est-ce que ça provoque soit des
migrations soit des guerres
strictement aucune idée soit des émeutes
soit des révolutions et personne ne peut
le dire n'importe quoi entre maintenant
et plus tard c'est typiquement ce à des
choses qui nous prendrons par surprise
c'est absolument évident une partie des
surprises ça viendra de la wii
oui il est interprétable il ya un gros
risque quand il ya une grosse
incertitude je le répète il ya un gros
risque
ça veut dire que vous ne pouvez pas
exclure la possibilité que vous soyez là
soit dit en passant l'année dernière en
europe en 2018
vous avez eu une baisse de rendement de
20 à 30 % dans certaines cultures
l'époque de terre partie des céréales
etc en russie en 2010 vous avez eu une
baisse de 45% de la production de
céréales etc le début du 21e siècle
alors on
il peut y avoir des augmentations sauf
que si vous comparez la russie et la
pologne c'est pas les mêmes surfaces
cultivées c'est pas le même tonnage
d'accord donc vous avez vous pouvez
avoir des variations et puis par
ailleurs ça sert pas les mêmes marchés
c'est pas nécessairement les mêmes
céréales et la pomme de terre l'année
dernière ça a souffert chez tous mais on
a de mémoire
non c'est des variations annuelles alors
temps vous avez des stocks et les moyens
énergétiques d'avoir des stocks c'est à
dire des frigos des machins etc c'est
pas très grave
au moyen-âge quand on n'avait pas les
moyens d'avoir des stocks si on avait
une baisse de 40% de la production une
année donnée gens mouraient de faim
révolution donc là pour le moment c'est
l'énergie abondante qui nous permet de
nous adapter à beaucoup de choses mais
confère le deuxième cours l'énergie
abondante allait pas éternel et
l'essentiel de d les conséquences du
changement climatique vont s'intensifier
dans la deuxième moitié du xxième siècle
à un moment où l'énergie abondante pour
partie ne sera plus là qu'il va y avoir
un effet de tenaille
c'est pour ça aussi que les conséquences
sont particulièrement difficiles à
prévoir
en général les gens qui s'intéressent
aux conséquences du réchauffement
climatique qui résonne comme beaucoup de
spécialistes toutes choses égales par
ailleurs donc pour eux ça fait pas
l'ombre d'un doute qu'il y aura toujours
des engrais des tracteurs des
phytosanitaires efficace des chaînes du
froid etc
sauf que c'est pas sûr ou plus
exactement c'est sûr que ce sera
l'inversé au bout d'un certain temps
j'ai juste une question de temps dans
les autres conséquences du changement
climatique
on va changer la biodiversité
microbienne
alors quelque chose qui est très facile
à comprendre c'est que quand on chauffe
1 quand on chauffe un bouillon de
culture tant qu'on ne chauffe pas trop
si on cherche juste un peu les petites
bêtes aime bien ça et donc dans un monde
qui globalement se réchauffe on va avoir
tendance à favoriser l'augmentation de
la biodiversité microbienne qui a
tendance comme vous pouvez le voir ici à
être plus élevés quand on est dans des
endroits chauds
bon là c'est la bouteille à l'encré
c'est à dire que à part vous dire ça je
suis pas capable de vous en dire
beaucoup plus
mais c'est évident que viendra un moment
où il y aura des nouveautés en ce qui
concerne les maladies alors y'a pas que
ça comme un facteur déclencheur d'une
nouvelle maladie
loin s'en faut je vais pas détailler sa
juste ça ça c'est rigolo
enfin c'est rigolo dans pas rigolo du
tout vous avez ici pour le bangladesh en
eau
la variation de
deux des cas de choléra et en bas la
variation de la température de surface
de long du pacifique acp lorsque vous
voyez c'est que quand il ya une
augmentation de la température de
surface de l'eau du pacifique
il ya une enfant durant les vacances du
pacifique est vous avez une augmentation
du nombre de codes et choléra au
bangladesh
est ce que vous savez comment s'appelle
l'élévation de température du pacifique
est
ça s'appelle el niño
quand vous êtes en condition el niño
vous avez tendance à avoir une
modification du régime des pluies du
coup vous avez un
qu'est ce que j'ai à dire vous avez une
augmentation des eaux saumâtres au
bangladesh
c'est à dire des eaux qui mélange les
eaux de mer et les eaux douces qui
favorisent le développement du vibrion
du choléra et donc vous avez plus de
gens qui sont malades du choléra
donc voilà quelque chose personne je
pense n'aurait été capable de proposer à
l'avancé un raisonnement de cette nature
ça veut dire quand il ya une
augmentation de la température de
surface du pacifique crack vous allez
avoir plus de cas de choléra
voilà donc ça c'est typiquement le genre
de conséquences vous pouvez comprendre
après c'est très difficile de prédire
avant on va maintenant parler de
l'élévation du niveau de la mer ici vous
avez une représentation schématique très
schématique même des terres émergées
avec les montagnes sur lesquels il ya
des glaciers pour certains de l'océan et
des calottes glaciaires que vous avez
ici
alors tout ça participe à la variation
du niveau de l'eau la première chose qui
va se passer avec l'eau c'est que comme
je vous l ai dit tout à l'heure la
quantité de chaleur emmagasinée par
l'eau augmente
l'eau chaude a tendance à occuper plus
de volume que l'eau froide puisque l'os
dilate antenne chauffe et donc comme le
niveau de la bagnole au niveau du fond
de la baignoire ne varie toujours pas ça
veut dire que le niveau de la baignoire
augmente quand vous chauffer l'eau et
donc le niveau de l'eau monte
la deuxième chose qui va faire monter le
niveau de l'eau c'est quand vous faites
fondre un glaçon qui posait sur la terre
vous avez un premier glaçons ou première
série glace ont opposé sur la terre qui
sont les glaciers des moyennes latitudes
typiquement la mer de glace pour ceux
d'entre vous qui sont allés à la mer de
glace
vous avez peut-être vu que avant de
prendre le train du montenvers quand on
remonte vers le vers la gare là il ya
des escaliers en métal et le long des
escaliers en métal vous avez des
pancartes qui vous disent à quel niveau
était la mer de glace il ya dix ans il
ya cinq ans il ya vingt ans et c'est
extrêmement spectaculaire ça s'appelle
quelques mètres tous les cinq ans enfin
ça va à une vitesse hallucinante en
épaisseur évidemment et donc c'est tôt
puisqu'elle est plus dans la dans la mer
de glace
eh bien elle se retrouve dans la mer
après vous avez les calottes qui vont
avoir un impact sur le niveau de l'eau
alors les calottes peuvent avoir deux
types ou trois types d'impacts plus
exactement sur le niveau de l'eau il y
en a deux qui sont présentés ici le
troisième vous en parlerai après la
calotte
elle va de 3000 mètres d'altitude au
niveau de l'eau en gros puisque là où
elles veulent des icebergs là où elle se
termine vous êtes au niveau de la mer au
sommet de la calotte vous êtes à 3000 m
d'altitude
donc c'est comme entre pour reprendre
l'exemple de la mer fin pour faire le
lien avec la mer de glace c'est quand on
entre la vallée de chamonix et le
mont-blanc il fait pas exactement la
même température en bas de la calotte
vous allez avoir fréquemment des
températures positives à ce moment la
glace fond et contribue au niveau à
l'élévation du niveau de la mer mais au
sommet de la calotte
vous avez souvent des températures
négatives voire constamment des
températures négatives et donc là la
neige qui tombe elle retire de l'eau à
l'aber l'ont été dans la mer elle
s'évapore
elle tombe sur la calotte elle reste sur
la calotte donc ça ça fait baisser le
niveau de la mer
donc en ce qui concerne les calottes il
faut faire un bilan de masse qui est ce
qui tombe là - ce qui s'en va là et
c'est la différence entre les deux qui
vous dit si la calotte contribuent à la
hausse du niveau de la mer ou à la
baisse des niveaux de la mer quand la
calotte se forment sur la scandinavie
manifestement ce qui va leur est plus
important que ce qui va là et niveau de
la mer baisse ce que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
inverse ce qui se passe là est
supérieure à ce qui se passe là et donc
la calotte contribuer à l'augmentation
du niveau de la mer
la fonte de la banquise puisque vous
connaissez tous archimède n'a pas
d'impact sur le niveau de l'eau quand
vous faites fondre de la glace qui
flottent déjà à la surface de l'eau
monsieur archimède vous dit que ça ne
bouge pas le niveau de l'eau par contre
monsieur par archimède
c'est à dire le physicien vous dis que
ça a quand même un impact parce que vous
remplacez une surface particulièrement
réfléchissantes qui est la banquise par
une surface particulièrement absorbante
qui est de l'eau de mer et donc ça
accélère le réchauffement de l'eau de
mer qui entoure la calotte et ça ça
accélère la fonte ou la désagrégation de
la calotte donc ya pas d'effet direct
mais il ya un effet indirect la banquise
en l'occurrence fond c'est à dire que l
attendant ça c'est pareil de votre
vivant tant qu'il y aura des journaux et
des gens pour en parler et bien frais
régulièrement peut-être pas tous les ans
mais enfin tout et quelques années on
vous dira on vient de battre le record
des temps du minimum de la banquise à
fin septembre puis parce que le
processus a commencé et il va continuer
parce que l'élévation de température et
comme je le disais tout à l'heure plus
marquée en articles que partout ailleurs
il ya également une diminution de
l'épaisseur de la banquise qui est en
qui est en cours
donc non seulement diminue en étendue
mais elle diminue en épaisseur alors on
connaît l'épaisseur de la banquise
depuis les années 70 76 1 belge jean
lassalle est ce que vous savez pourquoi
qui a eu les moyens d'aller mesurer
l'épaisseur de la banquise depuis les
années 70 n'ont pas le pétrole cher que
le pétrole
des gens encore plus méchant que les
pétroliers
les chinois n'ont les chinois ont juste
un pétrolier les militaires quel
militaire
oui absolument les sous mariniers les
gens qui opéraient les sous marins
lanceurs d'engins donc le nom poétique
qu'on donne aux structures des missiles
nucléaires et bien mesurer l'épaisseur
de la banquise pour savoir s'il serait
capable de faire surface à toute
instance balagan sous la banquise et
donc ils mesurent l'épaisseur de la
banquise et donc on a des relevés des
séries longues sur plusieurs dizaines
d'années sur l'épaisseur de la banquise
donc on c'est comme ça que l baisse mais
la plus grosse surprise désagréable
potentiel pour les siècles à venir
c'est pas de tout ça que ça va venir
c'est des calottes le groenland a
commencé à fondre
on sait que le groenland a commencé à
fondre
d'abord parce qu'il ya des gens qui se
baladent dessus et surtout parce qu'on
est capable de faire de l'altimétrie
radar c'est à dire qu'il ya des
satellites qui se baladent dans la haute
atmosphère
enfin quelques centaines de km de la
terre et qui mesure avec des radars
l'épaisseur fond de l'altimétrie et donc
ils mesurent l'épaisseur de la calotte
si l'épaisseur de la calotte diminue
c'est que la calotte a commencé à fondre
une fois que la calotte a commencé à
fondre le processus s'auto accélère il
s'auto accélère pour plusieurs raisons
la première c'est que quand le sommes
mais quand la calotte fond son sommet
père en altitude si son sommet père en
altitude il est environné d'air plus
chaud et donc ça font encore plus vite
le deuxième processus par lequel sa
s'auto-entretient c'est que au sommet de
la calotte
vous avez des poussières qui sont amenés
par le vent ces poussières sont
absorbante pour le rayonnement solaire
or plus or la neige en surface elles
font mais les poussières n'ont donc plus
à fond plus la concentration en
poussières augmente puisque les
poussières ont été amenés avec la neige
en permanence donc vous vous retrouvez
avec une densité de poussière en surface
qui augmente donc une surface qui
absorbent plus le rayonnement solaire et
crac qui s'amplifie encore le processus
donc une fois que la calotte
groenlandaise et puis vous avez le
processus de la fonte de la banquise qui
élèvent aussi la température
de manière accélérée donc une fois que
ça a commencé ça s'arrête plus donc la
calotte groenlandaise elle est partie
pour fondre partiellement ou en totalité
dans les siècles qui viennent en ce qui
concerne l'antarctique
vous voyez ici là aussi le résultat
d'une altimétrie radars et vous voyez
que l'antarctique de l'ouest et en
particulier cette partie là de
l'antarctique de l'ouest a commencé
également à perdre du volume
alors là le processus qui est à l'oeuvre
est un peu différent il se trouve que
l'antarctique de l'ouest repose sur un
socle rocheux qui est sous marins et qui
est des versants c'est à dire que plus
vous vous éloignez de la côte et plus il
est profond d'accord à partir du moment
où vous avez les langues terminal des
glaciers qui commence à se rétracter
parce que la température de la mer
augmente et que la mer
se soulèvent un peu eh bien vous avez un
processus de déstabilisation et de glace
qui est rongée par en dessous qui
s'accélère encore est par ailleurs cette
antarctique de l'ouest est posée sur un
socle qui est en pente et donc c'est une
espèce de système barque du temps chaque
glaciers en gros consolide les glacier
voisin
et quand vous avez les glaciers
terminaux qui sont près de la mer qui
commence à se déstabiliser
vous avez le système d' arc boutant qui
commence à se déstabiliser et donc il ya
la possibilité pour l'antarctique de
l'ouest d'une désagrégation total de
l'antarctique de l'ouest en quelques
siècles
si la température monte de plus de 2
degrés est donc comme la température va
monter de plus de 2 degrés voilà ça je
place il est assez vraisemblable que on
va mettre en route une désintégration
partielle ou totale là aussi de
l'antarctique de l'ouest à l'échelle de
quelques siècles si vous avez des
simulations qui ont été faites très
récemment oui ça c'est 2016
est ce que vous voyez c'est que avec le
scénario dans lequel on n'aimait plus
demain matin tout va bien mais avec le
scénario 4.5 qui est pourtant un
scénario pas très émissifs eh bien on a
déjà une contribution de l'antarctique
possible de 5 mètres dans les siècles
qui viennent et avec le scénario plus
émissifs on montre carrément à 12 alors
les 5 à 6 ici à plus de deux degrés on
est raisonnablement assuré de se les
prendre dans le même temps on se prend
trois à six en provenance du groenland
et dans le même temps on se prend
au moins un maître sur la dilatation de
l'eau de mer à cause de la température
oui alors elle sera pas nécessairement
homogène j'y reviendrai après pour vous
donner une idée de ce que ça représente
quelques mètres en plus dans l'océan
mondial vous avez ici une carte dans
laquelle on a mis en bleu foncé les
endroits qui sont noyés donc là vous
avez bangkok par exemple qui sont noyés
avec une élévation de 9 mètres du niveau
de la mer et là vous avez shanghai
maintenant ce que ça c'est nord de
l'europe
donc voilà on parlait tout à l'heure des
migrations et les flamands vont envahir
les wallons déjà qu'ils s'entendaient
pas ça va pas s'améliorer d'envoyer
alors jusqu'à il ya six mois ce qui
provenait de la communauté scientifique
c'était c'est un risque à l'horizon de
quelques siècles
il ya maintenant trois ou quatre mois
il ya des publications qui sont sortis
avec des gens qui disent ça pourrait
aller plus vite que ce qu'on imaginait
alors plus vite que ce qu'on imaginait
c'est pas la semaine prochaine
mais peut-être que déjà au bout d'un
siècle il va se passer des choses très
significative voilà là c'est pareil on
est rentré dans un grand point
d'interrogation
le grand point d'interrogation legrand
la grande la grande particularité de
points d'interrogation c'est que
personne ne peut répondre mais donc ça
veut dire que personne ne peut vous
proposer une borne inférieure des
emmerdements possible j'insiste là
dessus donc la grande incertitude
j'insiste c'est un gros risque question
est-ce que ça va se manifester de
manière continue réponse non vous avez
aujourd'hui une idée de pour ceux
d'entre vous qui sont des relais en
bretagne excellence région au demeurant
vous avez vidé de la hausse du niveau de
l'eau qui est comme l'appareil qui monte
sur la plage en corse un truc et c'est
tout doux tout doux tout doux tout doux
puis en général vous êtes au bord de la
plage quand il fait beau vous y êtes pas
quand il ya une tempête efforts se
disent donc vous voyez vous voyez il
c'est beau et peu trop de vente s'est
arraché un monde tout doucement mais bon
si ça vous mouiller un peu les pieds va
avoir très peur que la serviette et tout
va bien alors on a tendance à oublier
et dans cette image là que après que
l'eau soit monté elle redescend qu'elle
ne monte pas plus haut qu'un certain
niveau et que ça se passe alors qu'il
fait beau qui fait tout et puis que ça
ne concerne que du sable puisque vous
avez la laisse de haute mer
c'est encore du sable donc tous l'estran
et couverts de sable et donc ça c'est
une zone qui est prévu pour ça en ce qui
concerne la montée du niveau de la mer
les choses vont se présenter de façon un
peu différente parce que vous avez un
milliard de trucs humain qui intéresse
les hommes qui sont construits en bord
de mer
vous avez les ports les ports en mai en
pleine terre c'est plus qu'un vote de
l'est d'abord en bord de mer bon mais
sauf que les ports ne supporte pas une
élévation a défini du niveau de la mer
parce que si vous avez une élévation
trop forte du niveau de la mer vous
noyez toutes les infrastructures qui
sont installés sur les ports vous avez
plein d'entrepôts des stocks de toute
nature des terminaux ferroviaires etc
ces trucs là aiment pas trop être noyé
par de l'eau de mer vous avez les
raffineries
parce qu' énormément du enfin une grande
partie du raffinage conserve du pétrole
qui est amenée par bancaire et là c'est
plus commode d'avoir le temps car sur
locaux au milieu de la brousse donc les
raffineries sont en bord de mer vous
avez énormément de centrales électriques
qui sont en bord d'eau pour le
refroidissement par exemple toutes les
centrales électriques japonaise pas
juste nucléaires sont en bord de mer en
première approximation
vous avez des silos agricoles parce
qu'une bonne partie du commerce des
céréales se fait par vraquier donc les
silos agricole vous en avez une bonne
partie qui sont en bord de mer etc vous
avez plein de trucs importants qui se
trouve en bord de mer vous avez aussi
quelques villes dont vous avez
énormément de choses qui sont en bord de
mer ces trucs là sont défendus contre
les agressions de la mer parce que de
temps en temps la mère se montre un peu
méchante
vous avez une tempête donc une grosse
dépression donc le niveau de l'eau monte
pour ceux d'entre vous qui regardent les
conséquences des tempêtes
vous avez en général dès ce qu'on
appelle des surcotes au moment de la
tempête c'est à dire que le niveau de la
mer monte énormément et ce niveau de la
mer qui vont énormément peu noyé tout un
tas de trucs qu'ils seront derrière
alors la hausse du niveau de l'eau
qu'est ce que ça va faire ça va
rapprocher du bord de mer toutes les
infrastructures dont je viens de parler
et c'est à l'occasion d'un phénomène
extrême comme y en a toujours eu et
comme un art a toujours eu à ce moment
la meilleure passe par dessus la défense
et fait d'énormes dégâts derrière
donc la hausse du niveau de l'eau ne
produira pas des conséquences de manière
douce et continue
d'accord c'est pas comme ça que ça va se
passer ça va se passer à l'occasion de
phénomènes discontinue violent c'est
comme ça que les phénomènes vont se
produire
vous avez également sur les plaines
basses quelquefois la conjonction d'une
tempête parce que c'est souvent l'hiver
que ça se passe ces trucs là et
d'inondations terrestres
parce qu'il a beaucoup plu et à ce
moment c'est la conjonction des deux qui
amènent de l'eau d'un côté de l'autre et
crack
vous avez un processus qui est
particulièrement destructeur pour ça je
veux pas c'est parce que les partants
vous avez également dans les
conséquences qui sont possibles donc je
vais venir au groenland une modification
de la circulation à large échelle que
vous avez dans l'océan à cause des
alizés qui pousse en permanence l'eau
dans le même sens
à l'équateur et de la force de coriolis
vous avez un grand mouvement de
circulation dans les océans du globe qui
s'organisent en gros de la manière
suivante c'est un grand mouvement
est-ouest en surface avec un
contournement de l'afrique par le sud et
un grand mouvement inverse en fonte avec
ici une plongée de l'eau alors pourquoi
est-ce que l'on plonge au sud du
groenland
parce que il se trouve que l'eau est
particulièrement dense quand elle est
particulièrement froide et
particulièrement salée or au sud du
groenland
vous avez de l'eau qui s'est enrichie en
sel parce que en remontant vers le nord
de l'atlantique
l'évaporation a conduit pour partie à
des précipitations qui sont allés en
europe et qui sont pas qu'ils n'ont pas
ruisseler au même endroit de
l'atlantique ça les fleuves
mettre de l'eau douce pas à l'endroit où
l'eau est passée en perdant de l'eau
douce et en se renforçant en selle et
quand vous arrivez au sud du groenland
au moment dont vous êtes dans une région
à formation de banquise et au moment où
la banque qui se forment la banquise et
de l'eau salée jolie mais elle est moins
salée que l'on de mer qui va donner
naissance et elle expulse de la saumure
au moment où elles se forment donc là
quand la banque qui se forment à l'ex
plus de la saumure ce qui veut dire que
l'eau qui ne gèle pas se renforce
brutalement en selle à ce moment elle
devient particulièrement froide c'est
l'hiver particulièrement salée et elle
plonge laquelle devient plus dense que
l'eau qui était en dessous et elle
plonge et cette plongée des eaux
profondes
ça fait 6 fond d'accord c'est un
mouvement descendant qui fait si fond et
c'est à cause de ce mouvement de siphon
que vous avez la dérive nord atlantique
qui remonte jusqu'au sud du groenland
est par ailleurs comme ce mouvement
enfouis la chaleur de surface c'est à
cause de cela que le réchauffement est
moins marquée au sud du groenland
parce que vous avez une pompe à chaleur
qui vous prend la chaleur en surface et
qui voulant fuit alors que cette pompe à
chaleur n'existe pas dans le reste de
l'océan d'accord et c'est l'existence
cette pompe à chaleur au sens premier du
terme poupe la chaleur que vous avez un
réchauffement qui est moins marqué tant
que cette plongée des eaux profondes a
lieu évidemment si cette plongée des
eaux profondes s'arrête et c'est une
question ça pourrait arriver à ce moment
la perte de chaleur de la surface par
enfouissement s'arrête également
et à ce moment vous n'avez plus cette
singularité au sud du groenland ça ça
vous dit la même chose
alors question est ce que cette
circulation pourrait s'affaiblir la
réponse est oui parce que dans un monde
soumis au réchauffement climatique est
bien le réchauffement des tropiques est
moins important que le réchauffement de
l'arctique donc la différence de chaleur
entre l'arctique et les tropiques
s'affaiblit et donc le fait que ça
s'affaiblissent ça affaiblit un peu
entre guillemets la différence de
potentiel entre les deux et donc ça va
affaiblir la circulation est-ce que vous
montre les simulations c'est que à peu
près tout prévoir ça c'est la baisse de
la circulation la dérive nord atlantique
alors la dérive nord atlantique
s'exprime hans fehr druck c'est des
millions de mètres cubes à la seconde
pour rappel le débit de la scène ces 400
mètres cubes à la seconde on n'est pas
en train de paris
des même nombre de vendeurs et bien il y
en a beaucoup qui pensent que ça va
baisser mais y en a aucune qui pensent
que ça s'arrêtait brutalement
cela étant il ya des épisodes dans le
passé où cette circulation s'est arrêtée
brutalement en périodes glaciaires à des
moments où il ya eu des énormes débâcle
d'icebergs qui ont eu lieu dans
l'atlantique nord et qui ont amené
tellement d'eau douce que l'eau n'était
plus assez dense parce qu'elle n'était
plus assez salée pour être capable de
plonger et à ce moment là circulation
s'arrête et on le constate avec des
modifications très rapide à très courte
échelle de la végétation en reprenant
retrouvant les pollens dans l'est dans
l'est dans les sédiments dans les
carottages de sédiments près dé près des
côtes
on se rend compte que la végétation a
changé du tout au tout en quelques
dizaines d'années et c'est improbable à
une modification de cette circulation
ta moyenne autre conséquence les
phénomènes extrêmes devraient
s'intensifier et c'est une c'est un
processus qui est déjà alors alors je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure je disais aux
cours précédent pardon les phénomènes
extrêmes c'est lié à une convection
entre une surface chaude et une
stratosphère froide et avec une
stratosphère qui se refroidit et une
surface qui se réchauffe
vous avez globalement et une évaporation
qui augmente vous avez globalement une
pompe convective qui s'intensifie donc
on s'attend logiquement à ce que tout ce
qui est hors nahd ouragans etc et
cyclones augmente lorsqu'on constate
c'est que le nombre de cyclones dans
l'atlantique nord a une tendance à
légèrement augmenté mais surtout leur
intensité a tendance à fortement
augmenté ici vous avez une évolution de
l'intensité des phénomènes cycloniques
dans l'attenté vous voyez que les
phénomènes de catégorie 4 et 5 ont
considérablement augmenté sur les
dernières décennies donc dit autrement
pour le moment il se forme peut-être un
peu plus de cyclones qu'avant pour très
clair par contre ce qui est très clair
c'est que vous avez des cyclones plus
intense qui apparaissent et en fait
c'est exactement ce à quoi on s'attend
pour le réchauffement futur vous avez
ici une carte alors c'est par bassin
puis pour l'ensemble de la planète mais
bon je vais vous donner ça
directement le point important c'est que
vous voyez que les précipitations
intenses et le vent maxime faire les
précipitations et le vent vont avoir
tendance à augmenter en intensité
dit autrement il n'y aura pas
nécessairement plus de phénomènes
cycloniques par contre en moyenne quand
il se formeront ils ont tendance à être
plus destructeur autre question qui est
posée est ce qu'on va modifier
l'oscillation ngo'o la niña alors pour
le moment la réponse est pas clair il ya
un début de tendance m'enfin bon voilà
c'est une question aussi parce que ça ça
amplifie les extrêmes j'ai envie de dire
décennaux parce que plus le niño et la
niña sont intenses et plus par rapport à
une tendance vous avez des extrêmes qui
sont importants autre conséquence de ce
qui est en train de se passer
l'océan va s'acidifier alors que l'océan
s'acidifient est quelque chose qui est
physique
une partie du co2 passent dans l'eau
c'est un équilibrage de pression
partielle
une fois que le co2 est passée dans
l'eau il fait une réaction où il va
amener de la formation
d'hydrogène aux carbonates je crois que
c'est comme ça qu'on dit maintenant et
10h plus donc il va acidifier l'eau vous
savez que le co2 dans les temps anciens
s'appelait l'acide carbonique
si vous lisez les romans de jules verne
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelait donc je
mets plus de co2 dans l'auge acidifie
l'eau il se trouve que l'acidification
que nous nous apprêtons à faire est
quelque chose qui là aussi est
extrêmement disruptive par rapport à ce
qu'a été le ph de l'océan au moins sur
les 25 millions d'années qui était
remarquablement stable et ici vous voyez
comment peut évoluer le ph à des
horizons de temps très court par rapport
aux échelles géologique
alors évidemment il ya un certain nombre
d'animaux dans l'océan qui sont habitués
à ce ph très stable à commencer par les
coraux mais également à commencer par un
certain nombre d'espèces qui ont besoin
de synthétiser du calcaire et notamment
de l'aragonite l'aragonite est une forme
de calcaire vous avez deux formes à
laquelle cité l'aragonite qui est
synthétisée par un certain nombre
d'espèces planctoniques qui se font des
petites coquilles et bien si elles sont
plus capables de se faire ces petites
coquilles ces espèces disparaissent donc
une partie du plancton et à risque dans
cette histoire là moi je vais passer
parce que j'ai pas le temps et ça je
vais passer parce que j'ai pas le temps
également
alors en bout de chaîne il ya nous ce
graphique est là pour rappeler que les
risques pour la santé c'est à dire les
risques pour l'espèce humaine
en fait ils viennent à la fois de choses
que nous avons déjà vu jusqu'à
maintenant encore une fois si on mange
pas on n'est pas bien mais après ils
peuvent venir de risques indirects c'est
à dire si c'est le voisin qui mange pas
et le voisin commence à se mettre dans
un état de guerre ensuite le voisin
arrive chez nous nous on peut avoir à
manger on va quand même être à risque à
cause du changement climatique
parce qu'on va avoir une conséquence qui
n'est pas une qu'en physique directe
mais qui est une conséquence
géopolitique je ne crois pas qu'il
existe un logiciel fiable de prévision
des guerres en tout cas à moyen et long
terme je pense pas que ce soit très
simple par contre quelque chose qui est
raisonnablement robustes comme
conclusion c'est qu'à partir du moment
où vous avez
1 vous avez un une mise sous tension
globale du système c'est-à-dire que vous
avez comme dans la tectonique des
plaques là des gens qui sont globalement
sous stress de façon croissante à la
surface de la planète
c'est pas très difficile de comprendre
que globalement les situations
conflictuelles vont augmenter pas très
difficile de comprendre que j'avais
globalement le cas dernier point je vais
vous montrer maintenant l'asservissement
du cycle du carbone et du climat qui est
une chose importante dans le dense qui
nous concerne alors vous avez ici un
diagramme qui vous représentent les flux
et les stocks de carbone sur terre avec
anouar la situation telle qu'elle se
présentait avant que les hommes ne fasse
quelque chose au climat et en rouge les
modifications qui sont intervenus au
milieu des années 90 par rapport à la
situation pré industriels alors ce que
vous dit ce graphique c'est que par
exemple en situation pré industrielle
l'océan échange du carbone avec
l'atmosphère pourquoi ça parce qu'il se
trouve que la capacité à dissoudre du
co2 de l'eau de mer est plus élevé quand
l'eau est froide donc partout à la
surface de la terre où vous avez des
courants qui refroidissent l'eau vous
avez un flux descendant de co2 donc par
exemple le gulf stream est une pompe à
ces odeurs la dérive dans l'atlantique
plus exactement et une pompe à co2 l'eau
se refroidit en montant vers le
groenland elle pompe du co2 al'inverse
le courant du labrador qui est un
courant qui vient du nord froid et qui
se et dont le se réchauffe en descendant
vers le sud
ça c'est un émetteur de co2 corps
évidemment le co2 qui a été absorbé un
moment et rémy à un autre le système
s'équilibre
vous avez un deuxième flux naturel de
co2 entre l'atmosphère et les terres
émergées qui est le cycle de la
végétation donc pour croître les plantes
prennent du carbone dans l'atmosphère
sous forme de co2 mais derrière les
plantes sont mangés soit par des animaux
macroscopique vous par exemple soit par
des animaux microscopiques c'est la
décomposition des végétaux morts et à ce
moment-là respiration restitue ce co2 à
l'atmosphère et dans la respiration vous
avez évidemment la respiration des
micro-organismes ce que vous constatez
c'est que avant contre hip hop le
système
les flux sont globalement équilibrés
donc vous faites ça et ça et ça et ça et
le run off ici et claque c'est équilibré
orlov c'est le lessivage par le locle et
puis arrive les hommes et femmes
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait nous on va
faire deux choses on va déforester et on
va déstocker des combustibles fossiles
dans les deux
cas de figure on va prendre du carbone
qui était dans un stock la végétation où
les combustibles fossiles et de coller
dans l'atmosphère ce faisant on augmente
la quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère
ce faisant on augmente la température de
l'atmosphère à ce moment comme la
température augmente l'eau en surface se
réchauffe et ça toutes choses égales par
ailleurs ça on voit plus de co2 dans
l'air c'est le processus dont je vous
avais parlé au moment de la variation
naturelle du climat en disant quand
c'est les paramètres astronomiques qui
réchauffe le climat ça vous envoie du
co2 dans l'air et ça amplifie le
processus mais dans le même temps comme
vous avez plus de co2 dans l'atmosphère
que dans l'océan en pression partielle
vous allez créer un flux descendant de
co2 de l'atmosphère vers l'océan alors
il se trouve que coup de chance entre
guillemets actuellement les deux sont à
peu près équilibré mais c'est un coup de
chance parce que l'un vient du
différence de pression partielle
l'autre vient d'une variation de
température en ce qui concerne les
terres émergées dans un premier temps en
plus de co2 dans l'air c'est plus de
nourriture pour les plantes donc les
plantes ont tendance à accroître la
photosynthèse
c'est comme ça qu'on accélère le
métabolisme des plants de tomates dans
les serres nantaise
si en enrichissant l'atmosphère en co2
grâce à croix un kilo de tomates de
serre nantaise c'est quasiment un kilo
de gaz mais dans le même temps
eh bien vous avez une augmentation de la
température qui favorise le métabolisme
microbien et donc la respiration des
microbes et donc l'émission de co2 par
les terres émergées
mais avec le temps il se trouve que
l'augmentation de température va
s'intensifier après que le co2 s'arrête
d'augmenter et donc à ce moment vous
allez avoir une intensification de
l'émission de carbone par les sols
vous allez avoir un affaiblissement de
la photosynthèse parce que les
écosystèmes dont de plus en plus mal
supporté l'élévation de température et
le stress hydrique et en ce qui concerne
l'océan
vous allez avoir une intensification du
co2 rejetées par l'eau
dans le même temps que les pressions
partiel vont finir par s'équilibrer et
donc le flux descendant on va se calmer
donc ce que je suis en train de vous
montrer c'est que ici vous avez un
ensemble de rétroaction positive
vous voyez qui font que le système a
malheureusement une capacité à
s'emballer à cause de la rétroaction du
climat sur le cycle du carbone alors ça
finira toujours par s'amortir ça finira
toujours par trouver un point
d'équilibré
mais malheureusement le point
d'équilibré est susceptible d'être
trouvé beaucoup plus haut et je vais
finir avec les échelles de temps
caractéristiques de cette affaire vous
avez ici une mise en perspective de la
façon dont les divers processus dont je
vous ai parlé vont s'échelonner dans le
temps
en ce qui concerne cette affaire dont
vous avez ici l'évolution dont la
manière dont les émissions de co2 vont
évoluer
vous voyez elle augmente et puis au plus
tard à cause de la limitation géologique
des stocks de combustible fossile
ça passe par un maximum et ça décroît
libyen au plus tard à cause de ça ça
peut décroître en plus tôt il faut
l'espérer
si toutes les conséquences que je viens
d'évoquer ne semble pas suffisamment
appétissantes pour que on décide que le
jeu en vaut la chandelle
à cause de l'inertie chimiques donc le
co2 est un oxyde donc chimiquement
stable à cause de l'énergie chimique du
co2 dans l'atmosphère
vous voyez que ce n'est pas au moment où
on passe le maximum des émissions que
l'on passe le maximum de la
concentration au moment où les émissions
commencent à baisser
c'est à dire au moment où soit vous êtes
en stress énergétique soit on a commencé
à faire des efforts d'un côté ou de
l'autre
de toute façon la première chose que les
gens vont voir c'est que la
concentration va continuer d'augmenter
c'est compliqué comme situation sert
vous dites merde ou bien on est de plus
en plus mal et on voit que la
concentration augmente quand même parce
qu'on a plus assez d'énergie ou bien on
va commencer à faire des efforts est ce
qu'on voit c'est que la concentration
augmente quand même dans tous les cas de
figure ça va être une situation un peu
compliqué à expliquer la température va
continuer à dériver longtemps après que
l'on ait passé le maximum d émission
très longtemps après que l'on ait passé
le maximum d émission et enfin en ce qui
concerne la réponse des océans et la
cryosphère là les conséquences vont
s'échelonner pendant des milliers
d'années après que nous ayons passé le
maximum des émissions alors je redis ce
que j'ai dit au moment où j'ai parlé d
inertie chimique du co2 dans l'air en
fait c'est un système le changement
climatique dans lequel il n'y a pas de
possibilité de guérir on peut prévenir
on peut s'adapter
on ne peut pas guérir au sens où on ne
peut pas supprimer la cause de la
maladie
c'est ça qu'il faut avoir présent en
tête donc ce que je redis même si c'est
pas extrêmement sympathique pour le pour
la génération éventuellement que vous
représentez c'est que c'est un processus
qui va malheureusement ne faire que
croître et embellir jusqu'à ce que je
meurs et jusqu'à ce que vous mourriez
quoi qu'on fasse de toute façon que on
travaille pour ses enfants en ce qui
concerne l'amortissement des
conséquences mais c'est à cette échelle
là que ça se passe
qu' il faut se garder de penser que ce
qu'on ne connaît pas est une absence de
risque parce qu'en général c'est comme
ça qu'on raisonne malheureusement c'est
pas comme ça qu'il faut raisonner en
l'espèce et enfin la dernière phrase
rebouc avec le premier cours et elle est
absolument essentiel une partie
significative de votre vie va se passer
dans un monde dans lequel l'accès à
l'énergie deviendra un problème
croissant pour une quantité croissante
de zones dans le monde ce qui veut dire
que la capacité de réponse au problème
va avoir tendance à s'affaiblir avec le
temps c'est une autre manière de dire
que on devrait affecter nos moyens à
s'occuper du problème tant qu'on en a
encore au lieu de penser que le temps
joue pour nous est que demain on aura
des drones des robots et de ces quads
artificielle qui permettra de gérer le
problème beaucoup plus facilement
qu'aujourd'hui
en fait comme c'est l'énergie qui au
premier ordre
le proxy d'une capacité à gérer
n'importe quoi si on en a moins
c'est pas malheureusement
essentiellement des trouvailles
techniques qui vont permettre de
compenser ça au premier abord ça
marchera pas bien
voilà à la prochaine fois